I'm Jennifer Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on the office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of the office and give exclusive behind the scene stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're the office ladies. Hello! Hi there!
我是詹妮弗·费舍尔，我是安吉拉·金西。我们一起出演过《办公室》，我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在制作终极的《办公室》重温播客，只为你。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有两个亲历者才能告诉你独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女郎。你好！嗨！
Today we're going to talk about Angry Andy. He's very angry. Off-S ladies. Hello! Hi there! Today we're going to talk about Angry Andy. He's very angry. He's very angry. This is season eight episode 21. It was written by Justin Spitzer and directed by Claire Scanlon. Would you like a summary?
今天我们要谈的是愤怒的安迪。他非常生气。办公室女郎。你好！嗨！今天我们要谈的是愤怒的安迪。他非常生气。他非常生气。这是第八季第21集。由贾斯汀·斯皮策编剧，克莱尔·斯坎伦执导。你想听总结吗？
Would I ever? Well, now that he's back in Scranton, Andy struggles to regain his job, his office, and his manhood, because Nelly stole his office, stole the manager position, and I guess maybe his ability to perform in other places. Yeah, she's really stolen all of his performance opportunities. Meanwhile, Ryan tries to win Kelly back after seeing her move on with Pam and Jim's handsome pediatrician, Ravi, who is very handsome, by the way.
我怎么会不想呢？好吧，既然他回到了斯克兰顿，安迪就在努力夺回他的工作、他的办公室和他的男子气概，因为奈莉偷了他的办公室，偷了经理职位，我想可能还有他在其他地方的表现能力。是的，她真的偷走了他所有的表现机会。与此同时，瑞安在看到凯尔丝与帕姆和吉姆英俊的儿科医生拉维（顺便说一句，他非常帅）继续交往后，试图重新赢得凯尔丝的芳心。
I need a dapper. Well, everyone, we had a new director for this episode. It was Claire Scanlon, who joined the office family in season five as an editor. She directed two episodes of the show, including this one. Angry Andy was her directorial debut, and she now directs all the time. She has been teamed up with lots of office alums.
我需要一个时髦的人。好吧，各位，我们这一集来了一位新导演。她就是克莱尔·斯坎伦，她在第五季作为剪辑师加入了办公室大家庭。她执导过该剧的两集，包括这一集。愤怒的安迪是她的导演处女作，现在她一直在导演。她曾与许多办公室校友合作过。
She's directed episodes of Unbreakable Kimmy Schmidt, never have I ever, Abbott Elementary, as well as Brooklyn 9.9, Blackish, and Fresh Off the Boat, Angela, our new crossover connection. And guess what, everyone? I'm telling you all of this, not just because we love Claire, but because she's sitting here right now with us. My God, such enthusiasm. Can you wake up with me every morning and get me ready for the day?
她执导过《我本坚强》、《好想做一次》、《小学风云》以及《神烦警探》、《黑人当道》和《初来乍到》，安吉拉，我们新的跨界联系人。而且你们猜怎么着，各位？我告诉你们这一切，不仅是因为我们喜欢克莱尔，还因为她现在就和我们坐在一起。天哪，真是热情。你能每天早晨和我一起醒来，帮我准备好迎接新的一天吗？
Yeah, I'm just ginger over with like your life summary. I love this. We're so excited for here. I'm really, really honored to be here. My goodness, what you guys have created is so phenomenal. Everyone's always talking to me about this podcast and you guys always are absolutely. When I'm on a set, people I work with, like everyone in comedy, I mean, and then of course, fans are obsessed with it. So as you already know, but yeah, no, and you guys were like, I I'm the cutting edge of doing podcasts like Okay, Claire, we have lots of questions for you. I know fans are gonna be so excited. You have such a unique perspective on the show I was cracking up because before you came here today you sent us some pictures
是的，我只是像你的生平总结一样走过。我太喜欢这个了。我们很高兴她能来。我真的、真的很荣幸能来到这里。天哪，你们创造的东西太了不起了。每个人都在跟我谈论这个播客，你们总是绝对的。当我在片场时，我合作的人，就像喜剧界的每个人，我的意思是，当然还有粉丝们都对它着迷。所以如你所知，但是，不，你们就像，我是做播客的前沿人物，好吧，克莱尔，我们有很多问题想问你。我知道粉丝们会非常兴奋。你对这部剧有着如此独特的视角，我当时笑得前俯后仰，因为你今天来这儿之前给我们发了一些照片
You sent a picture at Claire and I have known each other a very long time. Claire, how long have we known each other? I mean older than some people listening. I don't know if we see at least 20 years if not 25. I think it was our mid 20s when you were doing groundlings. Yes. Oh, well, that was 20, yeah. That was a long time ago. Claire sent a picture, and I have this picture somewhere too. It was a little slightly different angle, because I think a few people were taking it. I'm in full Western wear. I have a Western shirt, a cowboy hat.
你发了一张照片，克莱尔和我都认识很久了。克莱尔，我们认识多久了？我的意思是比一些听众还要老。我不知道我们有没有20年，甚至25年。我想那是我们二十多岁的时候，你在做爆笑剧团。是的。哦，好吧，那是20年，是的。那是很久以前的事了。克莱尔发了一张照片，我某处也有这张照片。角度略有不同，因为我想当时有好几个人在拍。我穿着全套西部服装。我穿着一件西部衬衫，戴着一顶牛仔帽。
We are sitting at a bar, and we are doing tequila shots. Yeah, that's accurate. That's my birthday. No. I can't remember why we were doing tequila shots. Yeah, that's accurate. Was it my birthday? No. I can't remember why we were doing that. Why were you dressed that way? Also, is that how you dressed? I was dressed in back in the middle.
我们坐在一间酒吧里，我们在喝龙舌兰酒。是的，这很准确。那是我的生日。不。我记不清我们为什么在喝龙舌兰酒了。是的，这很准确。那是我的生日吗？不。我记不清我们为什么要那样做了。你为什么穿成那样？还有，你平时就这么穿吗？我穿着在中部。
I think 25 years ago? I do remember one year for my birthday. I wore like my dad's cowboy hat. I guess I really was fond of it. I went through a phase. It was the 90s. I mean, I feel like that phase works for Taylor Swift today. So thank you. Okay.
我想是25年前？我确实记得有一年过生日。我戴着我爸的牛仔帽。我想我真的很喜欢它。我经历过一个阶段。那是90年代。我的意思是，我觉得那个阶段对今天的泰勒·斯威夫特很管用。所以谢谢。好吧。
I was something. I was all the cutting edge of everything. I do remember clear though of all of our friends, you were one of us that had their sh** together. You had like really good jobs and you were very responsible. You weren't showing up doing tequila shots in a cowboy hat. And I remember you were working on a lot of documentaries back then. You were editing. I remember going to a screening of one and being like, oh my gosh, she's like the real deal. So we always ask our guests, how did they get their job on their office? And can you tell us how you ended up working on the show and how you came to direct this episode? Absolutely. I went to grad school at USC and my very last class
我有点与众不同。我站在一切事物的前沿。不过我清楚地记得，在我们所有的朋友中，你是一个把生活打理得井井有条的人。你有着非常好的工作，而且你非常负责任。你不会戴着牛仔帽来喝龙舌兰酒。我记得你当时在做很多纪录片。你在剪辑。我记得去看过其中一部的放映，当时我就想，哦，天哪，她是来真的。所以我们总是问嘉宾，他们是怎么得到《办公室》的工作的？你能告诉我们你是怎么开始在这部剧工作以及如何执导这一集的吗？当然。我在南加州大学读研究生，我的最后节课
was editing. I learned to avid and my TA said, I don't want to be an assistant editor does anyone want my job. I want to go into cinematography and I said, I want a job out of grad school to start paying my student loans. And of course, because this is who I remember. I knew where. Yeah, and I was like, I'll take a job out of grad school to start paying my student loans. Of course, because this is who I remember who I was.
是剪辑。我学会了Avid，我的助教说，我不想当助理剪辑师，有人想要我的工作吗？我想从事摄影工作，我说，我想要一份研究生毕业后的工作来开始偿还我的学生贷款。当然，因为这就是我记忆中的我。我知道在哪里。是的，我说，我毕业后要找一份工作来开始偿还我的学生贷款。当然，因为这就是我记忆中的我。
Yeah, and I was like, I will take that job. And I worked with this wonderful editor named Arnold Glassman on a project called Frank Capri's American Dream. Yes. That was really my first job ever in this industry. It was the first high-deaf documentary ever. High-deaf-in-ish in television didn't exist. This was like 1997. So this was one of their first documentary ever. High-definition television didn't exist. This was like 1997.
是的，我说，我会接受这份工作。我和一位名叫阿诺德·格拉斯曼的优秀剪辑师在一个名为《弗兰克·卡普里的美国梦》的项目中合作。是的。这真的是我进入这个行业的 第一份工作。这是有史以来第一部高清纪录片。电视中的高清画质在当时并不存在。这大约是1997年。所以这是他们最早的纪录片之一。高清电视在当时并不存在。这大约是1997年。
So this was one of their first projects ever. But I also worked on a lot of heavy news, subject material, like dying to tell the story, which is about Dan Elden who was Joan to death in Somalia, soldiers of peace about these kids who were nominated for a Nobel Peace Prize for trying to get people in Colombia to vote. And then I just kind of veered on to more, not intentionally. I just liked working. I liked working with Arnold Glassman, and I also just liked editing. I worked a lot with the woman named Kara Thompson.
所以这是他们最早的项目之一。但我也参与了很多沉重的新闻题材，比如《渴望讲述的故事》，讲的是在索马里被虐杀的丹·埃尔登；《和平卫士》讲的是这些孩子们试图让哥伦比亚人投票而获得诺贝尔和平奖提名。然后我稍微转向了更多，并非有意为之。我只是喜欢工作。我喜欢和阿诺德·格拉斯曼一起工作，我也只是喜欢剪辑。我经常和一位名叫卡拉·汤普森的女士合作。
She was amazing. And it led to me doing a couple of documentaries about celebrities that were known for comedy. Carol Bonat, a woman of character, Bob Newhart, Unbutton, Carrie Grant, a class apart. These were all American masters. And I really enjoyed watching the canon of their work. So without even realizing what I was doing,
她太棒了。这让我得以制作了几部关于以喜剧闻名的名人的纪录片。卡罗尔·伯内特，一个有性格的女人，鲍勃·纽哈特，解开纽扣，加里·格兰特，独树一帜。这些都是美国大师。我真的很享受观看他们的作品全集。所以在甚至没有意识到自己在做什么的情况下，
I was getting such an education, both in comedy and comedy editing. And again, not meaning to, wasn wasn't like calculated in any way. And then I was working on last comic standing, and I was a supervising producer and supervising editor of that particular season. And I get a phone call from my friend, Grady Cooper, and he said, hey, I hear that there's this new spin-off of the office.
我获得了如此多的教育，包括喜剧和喜剧剪辑。同样，并非有意为之，也算不上经过任何计算。然后我在做《最后的漫画站》，我是那一季的主管制片人和主管剪辑师。我接到我朋友格雷迪·库珀的电话，他说，嘿，我听说《办公室》有一个新的衍生剧。
Can you put my name in the hat? Because I know you're friendly with Paul Lieberstein. And the same way I know Angela, I know Warren, I know Paul. We all just hung around in our 20s, just whenever someone wasn't where he was like, want to play tennis? Like it was just really casual in our 20s. So I said, oh yeah, sure, I'd be happy to.
你能帮我把名字放进候选名单吗？因为我知道你和保尔·利伯斯坦很熟。就像我认识安吉拉一样，我认识沃伦，我认识保尔。我们二十多岁时就在一起厮混，只要谁有空，他就说，想打网球吗？我们二十多岁时真的很随性。所以我说，哦，好的，当然，我很高兴。
And so I called Paul. And I said, my friend wants to put his name in the hat to edit. And he said, what about you? And I said, oh, that's so great. And there were 30 people up for the replacement for Dean Holland. Dean Holland went on to become the supervising producer and editor of Parks and Rec. And he left a hole that I was very happy to fill. I still remember my job interview. It was with Greg Mike sure. Paulie Brersin and John Salada.
所以我打电话给保尔。我说，我的朋友想把他的名字放进候选名单去剪辑。他说，你呢？我说，哦，太棒了。当时有30个人在竞争迪恩·霍兰德的接替者。迪恩·霍兰德后来成为了《公园与游憩》的主管制片人和剪辑师。他留下了一个空缺，我非常高兴能填补它。我仍然记得我的工作面试。那是和格雷格·迈克尔斯、保尔·利伯斯坦和约翰·萨拉达一起。
They were all in there, and Greg was just like rapid fire questions. Luckily, I don't think I was nearly as intimidated as I should have been. And I just didn't have anything to lose, because I already I was never even considering this, because I'd never edited narrative. I'd never ever, I'd only done documentary and sketch comedy and this was not in my wheelhouse. Which Greg probably loved that. He loved that. He loved that I came with no baggage, he said. So I got the job. There was a little bit of like, let's see if it goes all right and I guess it did because at the end of season five, three of the three editors on the office were
他们都在那里，格雷格就像连珠炮似地提问。幸运的是，我觉得我并没有像本该受到的那样感到恐吓。我没有什么可失去的，因为我从来没有考虑过这个，因为我从未剪辑过叙事片。我从来没有，我只做过纪录片和素描喜剧，这不在我的专业范围内。格雷格可能很喜欢这一点。他很喜欢。他很喜欢我没有带着任何包袱来，他说。所以我得到了这份工作。当时有点像，让我们看看一切是否顺利，我想确实很顺利，因为在第五季结束时，《办公室》的三位剪辑师都
nominated for Emmy's back here. So everyone did well. And then Dave Rogers and I continued and edited all the way through the end of the, so it was there for about five years. I started on season five and went through nine. Well, I just remember how seamlessly you fell into the fabric of the office family. Like just your personality, your take on things,
获得了艾美奖提名。所以大家都做得很好。然后戴夫·罗杰斯和我继续剪辑，一直到剧集结束，所以我大约在那里待了五年。我从第五季开始一直待到第九季。嗯，我只记得你是多么天衣无缝地融入了办公室大家庭的结构中。就像你的个性，你对事物的看法，
it was an immediate fit. Like whatever you brought to that interview, it was clear, probably to them, and then immediately clear to the rest of us, that you were like, oh yeah, of course it's her. It was wonderful to be there. I mean, it was a very atypical situation. I mean, I'm sure there's other situations like that,
这是一种即时的契合。无论你在那次面试中带来了什么，对他们来说很明显，然后对我们其余人来说也立刻很明显，你就像，哦，是的，当然是她。能在那里真是太棒了。我的意思是，那是一个非常非典型的状况。我的意思是，我确信还有其他类似的情况，
but to be all under one roof, to sit and eat lunch together, to have such pleasant working hours cross coverage that led to so many great comedic moments, the electricity on the set. Like, I remember whenever something cool was happening, we would just be like, they're doing something cool. Let's go, run. And we run across the haring lot and go see something
但能聚在同一个屋檐下，坐在一起吃午餐，拥有如此惬意的工作时间，跨界报道带来了如此多伟大的喜剧时刻，片场充满活力。就像，我记得每当有酷炫的事情发生时，我们就会说，他们在做酷炫的事。我们走，快跑。我们跑过停车场去看看
freaking cool. Like, there's a parking by an in a drawer. Run. Rain's got a drink. So everyone just wanted to be part of the cool, fun thing. Like, totally. I just want to watch it. That was the spirit of the show.
超级酷的事。就像，有个停车场的车在转圈。快跑。雷恩有酒喝。所以每个人都只想成为酷炫有趣事情的一部分。完全同意。我只是想看。这就是节目的精神。
It really was. It was like we were kids at school. Someone was doing something cool in the art room. Yeah. You know, it was really special and I've been chasing that ever since, you know, I mean, it Same. Yeah, same. How did you come to direct this episode? Had you said, you know what, I'd be really interested in directing an episode or did someone come to you? I think that both Dean Holland and Dave Rogers led the way for editors
真的确实如此。就像我们在学校的孩子一样。有人在美术教室里做酷炫的事。是的。你知道，这真的很特别，从那以后我一直在追寻那种感觉，你知道，我的意思是，我也是。是的，我也是。你是怎么开始执导这一集的？你曾说过，你知道吗，我对执导一集会很感兴趣，还是有人来找你的？我想迪恩·霍兰德和戴夫·罗杰斯为剪辑师
directing on this show. And I think it was a combination of those two gentlemen having paved the way and Greg's esteemed for editors. Like he really is... And I think that also has showrunners really do appreciate the editors. Like a strong editor is someone you really are happy to have because it ultimately means less work for the showrunner and less hours in a dark room. So because they had done that, it was season eight and I think there were some open
在这部剧中执导开辟了道路。我认为是这两位先生铺平了道路，加上格雷格对剪辑师的推崇。他真的很……而且我认为剧集运作人也确实很感激剪辑师。一个强大的剪辑师是你会很高兴拥有的，因为这最终意味着剧集运作人的工作减少，在暗室里的时间也减少。因为他们已经这么做了，所以到了第八季，我想有一些空缺的
slots and I thought I'd just give it a go. And then I went to Paul and Greg. Okay, so now you mentioned that you edited your own episode. I was a little surprised. I wondered like if you would prefer it. Do you prefer editing your directing? So it's a very specific question for editing Angry Andy and whether I wanted to edit that versus today. Okay, so I absolutely wanted to edit Angry Andy in case I messed up. No one would know!
名额，我想我姑且一试。然后我去找了保尔和格雷格。好的，现在你提到你剪辑了你自己的那一集。我有点惊讶。我想知道你是否会更偏爱它。你更喜欢剪辑还是执导？所以这是一个关于剪辑《愤怒的安迪》以及我是否想剪辑那一集与今天的非常具体的问题。好吧，我绝对想剪辑《愤怒的安迪》，以防我搞砸了。没有人会知道！
I could fix it! You could cover it in an edit. No one would know. How would you not get that other ad? I'm gonna just rezzled as you with something. And you'll never know I didn't write that coverage. I didn't get that shot. That any more season director might have gotten. So I was very, very, I think I must have come in over
我可以修复它！你可以在剪辑中掩盖它。没有人会知道。你怎么能拿不到其他镜头呢？我会用某种方式闪瞎你的双眼。你永远不会知道我没有拍那个角度。一个更有经验的导演可能会拿到那个镜头。所以我非常非常，我想我一定是在
the weekend so no one could even see me working on it. Today, I really don't think it's a good idea. I know Steven Soderberg does it. So hats off to him and the co-enbrothers. I think especially in comedy, you can get a bit myopic and have set love. good idea. I know Steven Soderberg does it. So hats off to him and the co-enbrothers. I think, especially in comedy, you can get a bit myopic and have set love. And I'm sure every actor feels this way too. It's something with hilarious. You know it hit. The crew was laughing. It took forever to set up the shot at all work beautifully. And you just
周末来的，所以没有人能看到我在处理它。今天，我真的认为这不是一个好主意。我知道史蒂芬·索德伯格就是这么做的。所以向他和科恩兄弟致敬。我认为，尤其是在喜剧中，你可能会变得有点目光短浅，对片场产生爱意。好主意。我知道史蒂芬·索德伯格就是这么做的。所以向他和科恩兄弟致敬。我认为，尤其是在喜剧中，你可能会变得有点目光短浅，对片场产生爱意。而且我确信每个演员都有同感。有些东西非常搞笑。你知道它成功了。剧组在笑。花了好长时间才把那个镜头设置好，一切都很完美。你只是
felt this kind of jubilation that isn't there when you watch it in the avid on the television monitor. It's just not there. And you have an editor be like, yeah, I don't care how long it to you to set up this shot It's not good. It's not funny. I didn't laugh and I don't care and you don't need to push the story forward And I like having that person that doesn't have you know attachment to it the way you might the whole industry is a very Collaborative one and I think that what was great about the office is that everyone was fine, all cylinders, and listening to everyone else. I think that's the key is listening because you can have a lot of creative people, but if they don't listen to one another, it's going to be a train wreck. Absolutely. And not only were they listening, they were encouraging. Like, everyone was a friendly
感受到了那种在电视监视器的Avid中观看时所没有的狂喜。它就是不存在。你会让一个剪辑师说，是的，我不在乎你花了多长时间来设置这个镜头，它不好。它不好笑。我没笑，我不在乎，你不需要推动故事发展。我喜欢有那样一个不像你那样对它有依恋的人。整个行业是一个非常合作的行业，我认为《办公室》棒的地方在于每个人都在火力全开，并且倾听其他人的意见。我认为关键在于倾听，因为你可以有很多有创意的人，但如果他们不互相倾听，那将是一场灾难。绝对的。而且他们不仅在倾听，他们还在鼓励。就像每个人都是一个友好的
year. And it wasn't scary in any way, shape or forms. And that's the set I walked onto. And, you know, Matt Sone came in the weekend before to help me prep. That's the director of photography who also directed himself. Jens Lada gave me this wonderful document. Okay. You shared this document with us. And our listeners know Jens Lada. She's been on the show.
倾听者。而且它在任何方面都一点也不吓人。这就是我走进的片场。而且，你知道，马特·索恩在周末前赶来帮我做准备。那是摄影指导，他自己也执导过。詹斯·拉达给了我这份精彩的文件。好的。你和我们分享了这份文件。我们的听众认识詹斯·拉达。她上过我们的节目。
We love her dearly. We share some of the advice that she gave you. I've opened up my computer. You still have it. You said you some of the advice that she gave you. I've opened up my computer. You still have it. You said you have it, say on your desk top. I mean, you can actually see it's on my desktop. It literally says Jen's great advice.
我们非常爱她。我们分享了她给你的一些建议。我已经打开了我的电脑。你还留着它。你说你有一些她给你的建议。我打开了我的电脑。你还留着它。你说你把它保存在桌面上。我的意思是，你实际上可以看到它就在我的桌面。上面赫然写着“詹斯的伟大建议”。
And it kind of gives you an idea of the environment. First time directors don't get this. Like first time directors don't get like on a TV sitcom. Don't get time with the DP over the weekend. Like these are exhausted. This was the cook. Yeah, this was the, I feel like the creative collaboration that we always talk about. Everyone wanted each other to succeed totally.
它有点让你对环境有个概念。第一次当导演的人可没有这个。就像第一次当导演的人在电视情景喜剧里不会在周末和摄影指导有时间相处。就像这些人都筋疲力尽。这就是厨师。是的，这就是我们常说的那种创意合作。每个人都完全希望对方成功。
All right, so here are Jim Saladas advice tips for you for directing. And by the way, these are great for anybody. Number one, try to sleep beforehand, but absolutely do not worry if you can't. Your adrenaline will kick in and take care of you. I swear. I can see her's like, I swear. Two, be prepared as possible. Figure out what you want to do and then be okay throwing it all away. Both things really help me planning and the ability to adapt to better stuff that comes along and just the vibe of being open to new stuff is good on stage. I just don't do that to this very day.
好的，这里是吉姆·萨拉达给你的执导建议。顺便说一句，这些对任何人来说都很棒。第一，在此之前尽量睡觉，但如果睡不着也绝对不要担心。你的肾上腺素会飙升并照顾好你的。我发誓。我能看出她就像，我发誓。第二，尽可能做好准备。弄清楚你想做什么，然后接受把它全部抛弃的准备。这两件事对我规划、适应随之而来的更好东西的能力，以及在舞台上保持开放态度的心态都非常有帮助。直到今天我还是这样做。
That's a great parenting advice too. That's these, a lot of these are gonna be good. It's how I kept for my weekend. I feel like a lot of these are gonna apply to different facets of life. Three, directing like everything has a learning curve. Somehow people think that with directors, they're just supposed to walk in on the first day
这也是很好的育儿建议。这些中的很多都会很有用。这也是我度过周末的方式。我觉得这些中的很多都将适用于生活的不同方面。第三，执导就像任何事情一样都有学习曲线。不知何故，人们认为导演们应该在第一天走进片场
and have all the answers, don't worry if you don't. For me reading the chapter in Shop by Shop was helpful about the line. She's talking about that. Yeah, don't cross the line. And that's just kind of how you set up shots and where you put the camera and relationship to the actor. She's like, but I can't imagine you need to do that, but it was really helpful for me. Editors have a pretty good idea about the line. It looks really wonky if you cross the line in something that you're editing. So I think inherently you just kind of know where that line is. Yeah, I still don't think I understand the line.
并掌握所有答案，如果没有也不用担心。对我来说，阅读《分镜头》那一章关于“越轴”很有帮助。她谈的是那个。是的，不要越轴。这只是你设置镜头以及相对于演员放置相机位置的一种方式。她说，但我无法想象你需要这样做，但这对我真的很有帮助。剪辑师对“轴”相当有概念。如果你在剪辑的东西中越轴，看起来会非常怪异。所以我认为你天生就知道那条线在哪里。是的，我仍然觉得我不太理解“轴”。
The line. It's like when you watch soccer and someone is off sides, I'll never get it. I've let it go. Same. But it's okay because we have amazing people like you once at. Don't cross the line doesn't mean don't do something inappropriate. Cross the line is jargon in the industry about how it's where it is at. Where it is at.
那条线。就像你看足球比赛时有人越位一样，我永远不会懂。我已经放下了。一样。但没关系，因为我们有像你这样棒的人在片场。不要越轴并不意味着不要做不恰当的事。越轴是行业术语，关于它的位置。它的位置。
Where it is at. Yeah. Number five, I do shots on those set blueprints. I think she's referring to overheads, which is basically like the schematics. Like when you're doing your house and somebody mocks up what your architect draws a plan of your house, it looks like a bird's eye view of your house. We have those, they're overheads,
它的位置。是的。第四，我在片场蓝图上画镜头。我想她指的是俯视图，基本上就像原理图。就像你盖房子时，别人把你的建筑师画的房子平面图做成模型一样，它看起来像你房子的鸟瞰图。我们有那些，它们是俯视图，
but Matt's own recommended little dolls so I could place them and think about shots. So she took little dolls and she just kind of put them on the overhead shots. Like that front reception or a reverse meeting. And yeah, exactly. So you could see it. So you could see where Angela
但马特·索恩推荐了小玩偶，这样我就可以把它们摆好并思考镜头。所以她拿了小玩偶，把它们放在俯视镜头上。就像前台接待处或反向会议。是的，完全如此。这样你就能看到了。这样你就能看到安吉拉
would be and when she walked over to the jelly means, you know, like, yeah, or better yet, where Brian would be. Number six, I tried to get a wide shot of most scenes. Some directors forget that as you know. And it helped a few times. But then again, you know what you need. I didn't, I didn't necessarily know what I needed. And I always, to this day, get wide shots or we also call masters of the scene. Just, you kind of know what the geography is. Like, oh, Pam is a perception. Angel is back there. You know, someone's walking out of the kitchen. You know, just kind of the geography
会在哪里，当她走到果冻豆那里时，你知道，比如，是的，或者更好的是，瑞安会在哪里。第五，我尽量为大多数场景拍一个广角镜头。正如你所知，有些导演会忘记这一点。这在几次帮了大忙。但话说回来，你知道你需要什么。我不知道，我并不一定知道我需要什么。直到今天，我总是会拍广角镜头，我们也称之为场景的主镜头。就是，你对地理位置有一种概念。比如，哦，帕姆在前台接待处。安吉拉在那后面。你知道，有人从厨房走出来。你知道，就是那种地理概念，
so that when you go in tighter, you don't get surprised if you hear Oscar shouting and you didn't see him before. I didn't know Oscar was there. As a viewer, you just kind of want to know who's in the room. Number seven, this is very true. The actors like to do a few takes in a row, so try to get ahead of schedule and when I could, like not shooting a tiny nothing seen a million times, could help me make up time
这样当你拉近镜头时，如果你听到奥斯卡在大喊而你之前没看到他，你就不会感到惊讶。我不知道奥斯卡在那里。作为观众，你只是想知道房间里都有谁。第六，这非常真实。演员喜欢连续拍好几个镜头，所以要尽量赶在进度前面，在可能的时候，比如不要把一个小得不能再小的场景拍上一百万遍，这可以帮我节省时间，
and have time for when the actors were pushing back and wanting to do more uninterrupted. It was so special in the office that we could do a couple in a row. If you watch some of the bloopers, especially with John Krasinski and Rainwellson, they'll make each other laugh and they would have this unspoken language and like acknowledgement where John would make rain laugh and then they would just start over again and they would just keep resetting themselves
并为演员们提出反对并想要更多不间断拍摄时留出时间。在《办公室》里最特别的是我们可以连续拍好几个。如果你看一些花絮，特别是约翰·卡拉辛斯基和雷恩·威尔森的，他们会逗彼此笑，他们会有那种默契的语言和确认，约翰会逗笑雷恩，然后他们就会重新开始，他们会一直重置自己，
and doing it over and over again until they got it right with no interference from the director at all. And it's really interesting to watch. And it was almost like they needed to get out their giggles. And then like on the seventh time they restarted, then they'd finally be able to finish the scene. That's like a dance.
一遍又一遍地做，直到在导演没有任何干涉的情况下做对。看这个真的很有趣。而且几乎就像他们需要把笑声释放出来一样。然后就像他们重新开始的第七次，他们终于能够完成这个场景了。这就像是一支舞蹈。
I am really loving Jen's list. Same. I can jump to eight. Despite what anyone suggests, trust your instincts, you're smart and not afraid to ask for help advice when you need it. This is Jen talking, not advice I got, it's highly face. And then she wrote nine.
我真的很喜欢詹斯的这份清单。一样。我可以跳到第八点。不管别人怎么建议，相信你的直觉，你很聪明，在需要时不要害怕寻求帮助和建议。这是詹斯在说话，不是我得到的建议，这是高度赞赏。然后她写了第九点。
Oh, and some of the better episodes came when the directors made sure it all tracked, made sense. She was amazing and said, you're going to be great. So excited for you. We must celebrate. Again, very friendly for a save work. I do remember thinking to myself when we broke for lunch, okay, I can do this. I can do this week.
哦，当导演确保一切都有迹可循、合乎逻辑时，一些较好的剧集就诞生了。她太棒了，说，你会棒极了。为你感到兴奋。我们必须庆祝。再次说明，对于一份工作来说非常友善。我确实记得当我们在午餐休息时对自己说，好吧，我可以做到。我能搞定这周。
I've got this. And I remember the volume of questions. And it's not like they're like all hard questions. It's just the volume, the number, red cup or blue cup, blue pen, purple pen, should, so on and so forth. This is when you're the bride. I mean, it's a place are linen. I don't know, like, yeah, you can do it.
我能行。我记得问题的数量。这倒不是说都是很难的问题。只是数量，数量，红杯子还是蓝杯子，蓝笔，紫笔，应该，诸如此类。这是当你当新娘的时候。我的意思是，这是一个亚麻布料的地方。我不知道，比如，是的，你可以做到。
And you know, what I've learned subsequently is I just always have an answer. And then, you know, if you're like, I don't care if it's a red cup or a blue cup, just have a answer. But to the prop person, that's their job. And it's really important for them. They've taken a lot of thought and care into it.
你知道，我后来学到的是，我总是先给出一个答案。然后，你知道，如果你觉得，我不在乎它是红杯子还是蓝杯子，只要给出一个答案。但对道具人员来说，那是他们的工作。他们为之付出了很多思考和关怀。
To have an answer is good. I'll say red cup. And then I'll go quietly, call my mind, think about it, and be like, no, the whole set is red. We need more blue in this, you know, shot. I don't want it to, you know, seem like it's an angry scene, because there's just the color red is too sharp. So then I go back and say, I've changed my mind.
给出一个答案是好的。我会说红杯子。然后我会悄悄走开，开动脑筋思考，然后想，不，整个布景都是红色的。我们需要在这个镜头里有更多的蓝色，你知道。我不想让它，你知道，看起来像是一个愤怒的场景，因为红色的颜色太刺眼了。所以我回去说，我改变主意了。
I'd like blue, but the worst answer you can ever give is I don't know, because that just makes you look like you're not going to do your job. Oh, that's interesting. So make a choice and then reflect on your choice and if you need to change your mind, change your mind. Yeah, it's better to be decisive and it helps people see you as a leader.
我想要蓝色，但你给出的最糟糕的答案是“我不知道”，因为那只会让你看起来无法完成工作。哦，这很有趣。所以做一个选择，然后反思你的选择，如果你需要改变主意，就改变主意。是的，果断一点更好，这有助于人们视你为领导者。
Yeah, so at lunch, I was like, okay, I can do this. It's a lot of questions and it's a lot of pressure. I can do this. Why would anyone want to do this? This is so intense. And then by the end of day one, I was like, I love this. I only want to do this. It was such a transition from halfway through the day.
所以，在午餐时，我想，好吧，我能做到。有很多问题，也有很多压力。我能做到。为什么会有人想做这个？这太紧张了。然后到了第一天结束时，我心想，我太爱这个了。我只想做这个。从一天中间的状况转变过来了。
I don't know, I think I just got used to it. It really, but I remember that it was a halfway mark was like, I'm going to do this, I'm gonna barrel through, I can do it. And then at the end, something shifted and I loved it. I have a question for you. A big portion of this episode plays out in the conference room. And I noticed
我不知道，我想我只是习惯了。这真的，但我记得在中间阶段时觉得，我要做到这一点，我要硬着头皮冲过去，我能行。然后到了结束时，情况发生了变化，我爱上了它。我有一个问题要问你。这集很大一部分情节是在会议室里展开的。我注意到
that you set up the table with chairs around it instead of doing the rows, and I went I looked at the script for Angry Andy, and it didn't say it just said everyone gathers in the conference room. Did you get to pick? Did somebody ask you the question? Table or rows? They do ask the question. I chose the table because I wanted it to feel more claustrophobic in the room that people were more stacked next to each other that Aaron felt a little bit more trapped. I also wanted it to make more sense
你把桌子周围摆了椅子，而不是排成一排，我去看了一下《愤怒的安迪》的剧本，上面并没有写，只写了大家聚集在会议室里。你是自己选的吗？有人问过你这个问题吗？桌子还是排数？他们确实问了这个问题。我选择桌子是因为我想让房间里感觉更幽闭恐惧，人们挨得更近，让艾琳感觉更被困住。我也想让它更合理
that Andy doesn't see impotence on the whiteboard and thinks it says importance when he walks in. It's there's not as much space because there's this big table in the way. So it's two people leading a conference. It's more that people are all surrounded this table so that when people start talking about crazy stuff, like Phyllis's two year long orgasm,
安迪走进来时，不会把白板上的“阳痿”（impotence）看成“重要性”（importance）。没有那么多空间，因为中间有这么大一张桌子。所以这是两个人主持一场会议。更多的是人们都围着这张桌子，当大家开始谈论疯狂的事情时，比如菲利斯长达两年的高潮，
or then when finally Aaron's like, Toby, is there something that you can do, HR have anything to do, and he's like, my job is nothing, that you can teach or have anything to do? And he's like, my job is nothing. I have nothing. I can't do anything anymore. You kind of feel like, you know, it's very stacked. And her ex-boyfriend is two people down from her when he tells her you said having sex
或者当艾琳终于说，托比，有什么你能做的吗？人力资源有什么办法吗？他说，我的工作什么也不是。你有什么能教的或能做的吗？他说，我的工作什么也不是。我什么也没有。我什么也做不了了。你会有一种，你知道的，堆叠在一起的感觉。当前男友告诉她你曾说过做爱
was like two skeletons wrestling. So which by the way, was outlived and made- I checked the script. I did too. You felt like skeleton was tackling you. Yes. I checked the script because I noticed Jenna that you and I broke.
就像两个骷髅在摔跤时，她的前男友就在她隔两个人远的地方。顺便说一句，那句台词超出了剧本并即兴发挥——我查了剧本。我也查了。你会觉得骷髅在向你扑来。是的。我查了剧本，因为我注意到詹娜你和我笑场了。
I noticed that I actually cover my face because Zach Woods is so good at improv. Incredible. Incredible. So good. Which scene from this episode did you have to prep the most? Can I guess? Can we guess what would you think?
我注意到我其实捂住了脸，因为扎克·伍兹太擅长即兴表演了。不可思议。不可思议。太棒了。这一集里哪个场景你必须做最多的准备？我能猜吗？我们能猜猜你会怎么想？
Go for it. The horse, because the head of horse? I was gonna say the horse and all the, or the punch the wall. I'd say the punch the wall, because that required stun, set deck and props, as well as the glass, we had to make sure the glass wouldn't go, it was like a glass on your,
猜吧。马，因为马的头？我本来要说是那匹马和所有的，或者是拳击墙。我会说是拳击墙，因为那需要特技、布景和道具，还有玻璃，我们必须确保玻璃不会飞出去，就像你身边的玻璃一样，
this picture. We were really had to be careful the glass wouldn't go. It was oh, I'm really picture. I'm in this picture. You had to be really careful about because he really wanted to throw it down hard. So it was a lot of the technicalities of that and putting your, you know, your hand making sure that it wouldn't really actually hurt any done it before. So that was good. But like he wouldn't really hurt his hand. We did a couple of tests just, you know, with drywall squares, just to make sure it was good. I see so afraid in the moment I would miss the spot and I'd break my hand or something. Yeah. He was good. I think in relationship to where the nail was of Nelly's portrait,
这张照片。我们真的必须小心玻璃不会飞出去。那是，哦，我真的在照片里。我在这张照片里。你必须非常小心，因为他真的很想狠狠地把它砸下去。所以其中有很多技术问题，把你的手放好，确保它不会真的伤到以前做过的人。所以那很好。不过他不会真的伤到自己的手。我们做了一些测试，你知道，用干墙方块，只是为了确保没问题。我当时吓坏了，生怕自己错过那个点，砸断手什么的。是的。他很棒。我认为相对于奈莉肖像的钉子所在的位置，
he knew exactly to go just directly down. Geez. So, whereas the person that was the horse, whenever there's animals on set, I feel like the animals are there for a while. That horse was really chill, a very slow-boring horse. It was really easy to manipulate that horse. I feel that the handler was great. One big element was that nobody that needed to act around the horse was scared of the horse. Yeah. So you know my dad works with horses. And he said that they can sense your heartbeat. And so if you're nervous, it makes them nervous. So that's really good.
他知道该怎么直接砸下去。天哪。至于那匹马，每当片场有动物时，我觉得动物会在那里待上一会儿。那匹马真的很冷静，是一匹非常慢、很无聊的马。操纵那匹马真的很简单。我觉得驯马师很棒。一个很大的要素是，需要在马周围演戏的人没有一个人害怕这匹马。是的。所以你知道我爸爸跟马一起工作。他说它们能感受到你的心跳。所以如果你紧张，就会让它们紧张。所以这真的很好。
Right. It was a huge, it's a huge thing. And horses are just also they have such empathy. Yeah. That's why they do all of that great therapy work. That's what my dad does with horses. That's the horses. The horses do therapy work with autistic children. And he's one of the horse handlers. Yeah. That's an amazing job.
对。这是一件大事，马也同样具有如此强大的同理心。是的。这就是为什么它们要做所有那些棒极了的治疗工作。我爸爸就是跟马做那个。那是马。马和自闭症儿童一起做治疗工作。他是驯马师之一。是的。那是一份了不起的工作。
That's an amazing, how gratifying because I'm that's an amazing job. That's an amazing. How gratifying because I'm sure he sees the difference. It's like night and day. Yeah, and horses are so smart. So smart. So smart. I noticed in the script that the throwing of the carmels was not scripted originally. Aaron was just supposed to throw the pens
那是一份了不起的工作，多么有成就感，因为我确信他看到了区别。就像黑夜和白天一样。是的，而且马非常聪明。非常聪明。非常聪明。我注意到剧本里扔焦糖并不是原本设定的。艾琳本来只是应该扔钢笔
and throw the messages. And then she throws those carmels. And I felt like when I was watching, the reason I went to the script was because I felt like Catherine Tate was legitimately surprised that she was having to dodge carmels. Yeah, I feel like everyone kept Catherine on her toes on that show. Yeah. Well, was there anything else you prepped, special for Angry Andy?
和扔便条。然后她扔了那些焦糖。我觉得当我观看时，我去看剧本的原因是因为我觉得凯瑟琳·泰特是真的对不得不躲避焦糖感到惊讶。是的，我觉得每个人在那个节目中都让凯瑟琳保持警惕。是的。好吧，为了《愤怒的安迪》，你还做了什么特别的准备吗？
When preparing to direct Angry Andy, it was the first time that we would be seeing Nelly as manager in that office space and that office space for the manager. So iconic. Yes. And so when we had how it's decorated, exactly how it's decorated. So fun. And her throw. And I wanted to make sure that we had enough time to establish the space,
在准备执导《愤怒的安迪》时，这将是我们第一次看到奈莉在该办公室空间担任经理，而那个办公室是经理的办公室。太标志性的了。是的。所以当我们确定它是如何装饰的，确切地说是如何装饰的时。太有趣了。还有她的投掷。我想确保我们有足够的时间来确立空间，
but also keep things interesting with Andy. So a way in which to put the things in her office that set Deitke deemed worthy of her. And we also went through that as well. But also making sure they were placed in such a way that it could organically be revealed with Andy and Nelly having their stand off of her thing. I'm not leaving. And then that's where she says, Angela, $100 for me.
同时也让安迪的戏份保持趣味性。所以要在她的办公室里放一些道具布景认为配得上她的东西。我们也经历了这个过程。但也要确保它们的摆放方式能够自然地展现出来，安迪和奈莉就她的东西进行对峙。我不会离开的。然后这就是她说的那句，安吉拉，给我100美元。
On it! On it! Like, crickets when Andy does the same, which is a wonderful payback for Angela to do, Tandy. And so definitely wanting to make sure that you really felt her presence and how thoroughly and sconce she was into that new manager's office.
马上！马上！就像当安迪也这么做时一片死寂，这对安吉拉来说是向安迪进行回击的绝妙方式。所以绝对想要确保你真正感受到了她的存在，以及她如何彻底地在这个新经理办公室里安顿下来。
And those scenes were tight and you wanted it to feel like a high-noon moment, like they're against each other. Yeah. And just making sure that in that small space you still got that kind of awkward vibe of them facing off against each other. I thought the office was decorated so well and it was very clear immediately that all of Andy's things had been wiped from the space and that it was a totally new space. So I thought that was great.
而那些场景很紧凑，你想让它感觉像是一个正午对决的时刻，就像他们针锋相对一样。是的。并且只要确保在这个小空间里，你仍然能感受到他们面对面时那种尴尬的氛围。我觉得办公室装饰得太棒了，而且立刻就能看出安迪的所有东西都被从这个空间里抹去了，这是一个全新的空间。所以我认为这太棒了。
Oh cool, I'm glad it worked. Yeah, totally. And actually in rewatching it, I was like, oh, the office is different. And I see it. You notice it right away. Yeah. Yeah. We always ask everyone when the show ended, did you take anything? Because we took lots of stuff. Okay, give it up, Claire. I got permission from Greg to take, and I feel now I need to pass it along because I feel like it's such a good thing.
哦，太酷了，很高兴它起作用了。是的，完全如此。事实上，在重温时，我心想，哦，办公室不一样了。我看到了。你马上就能注意到。是的。是的。每当剧集结束时，我们总是问每个人，你拿了什么东西吗？因为我们拿了很多东西。好吧，招了吧，克莱尔。我得到了格雷格的允许拿了，我觉得现在我需要把它传下去，因为我觉得这是一个如此美好的东西。
What? What did you get? I got the ducky that would ruin takes. Yes! Oh my God! We have talked about this stuff. I have the ducky. I still have it, it's on my bookcase.
什么？你拿到了什么？我拿到了那个会毁掉镜头的鸭子玩具！是的！天哪！我们谈过这个。我拿到了鸭子。我还在留着它，它在我的书架上。
I think you do deserve that. Either you or someone from Sound deserves that stuff. I have the note. I still have it. It's on my bookcase. I think you do deserve that. Either you or someone from Sound deserves that. I thought everyone's so neat. Because it takes. I made it hard for you to edit things. But Sarah Levy was in the office when John Burstin looking for something he hadn't thought it through. Like, this is over.
我觉得你绝对配得上那个。要么是你，要么是音响部门的某个人配得上那个东西。我有那个便条。我还在留着它。它在我的书架上。我觉得你绝对配得上那个。要么是你，要么是音响部门的某个人配得上。我觉得每个人都觉得很整洁。因为这会毁掉镜头。这让我很难剪辑东西。但萨拉·利维在办公室里，当时约翰·伯斯特在找他没考虑周全的东西。就像，这结束了。
And he was like, what can I take with you? And he started to go for the Ducky and Sarah was like, Greg already promised that to Claire. So John, so now I feel a little bit like, I've had my time with the Ducky. My kinship actually played with the Ducky. It still works. It does, it still works.
然后他说，我可以带走什么？他开始去拿那只鸭子，萨拉说，格雷格已经把它答应给克莱尔了。所以约翰，所以我现在有点觉得，我和那只鸭子共度了我的时光。我的亲戚实际上玩过那只鸭子。它还能用。是的，它还能用。
It's so loud. It's about what go hit it every time she was on set. Because it's fun and cute. So many good bloopers with that Ducky. Well, one of the questions we always end and interview with is, was there any favorite memory from your time on the show? Anything you would want to share with us? I would say there's too many, and I'm sure that so many people say the same answer, especially
声音太大了。每次她出现在片场时，都会去捏它。因为它又有趣又可爱。那只鸭子带来了好多精彩的花絮。好吧，我们采访结束时总是会问的一个问题是，在节目期间有什么最喜欢的记忆吗？有什么你想和我们分享的吗？我想说有太多了，我确信很多人都会给出同样的答案，特别是
when you're there day in and day out, you know, working there for such a long extended period of time. There's just too many wonderful moments. It's an impossible question, but my personal relationship to a scene and a moment would have to be Niagara. And the reason why it had such fun and comedy and the walking down the aisle to the song
当你日复一日地在那里，你知道，在那里工作了那么长的时间。有太多美好的时刻了。这是一个不可能回答的问题，但我个人对某个场景和时刻的联系一定是尼亚加拉瀑布。原因在于它有那么多的乐趣和喜剧色彩，以及伴随着那首歌曲走向红毯
that was such a moment in the YouTube history of people doing that and the comedy there, but intercutting it with the footage that Randall shot at Niagara Falls with Pam and Jim when they actually got married versus the one where everyone else thought they got married, intercutting that and finding that last shot where Jim is holding Pam and they're looking out over the water. And then he turns to the camera. That shot, it was like one of those disfighted.
那是YouTube人们模仿这一行为历史上的一个重要时刻，其中的喜剧效果，但将其与雷恩在尼亚加拉瀑布拍摄的帕姆和吉姆实际结婚的镜头与其他人以为他们结婚的镜头进行交叉剪辑，交叉剪辑并找到最后一个镜头，吉姆抱着帕姆，他们眺望水面。然后他转向镜头。那个镜头，就像那些不经意的。
He knew to do it, you probably felt it. It was such a magical shot. And then getting to show you and John in my edit bay, you guys came in just like we were talking earlier, actors would just come in and be like, and you both wanted to see that scene cut. You know, you're wetting scene, you wanted to see it and show us. And being so nervous for you to see how I did it,
他知道该怎么做，你可能感觉到了。那是一个如此神奇的镜头。然后能让在我的剪辑室里看到你和约翰，你们俩就像我们刚才说的，演员们会走进来，比如，你们俩都想看那个场景剪辑。你知道，你们的婚礼场景，你们想看并向我们展示。能为你们看到我做得怎么样而感到如此紧张，
and then turning around and seeing you guys were both crying, I was really great. And I was like, and I knew it was that last moment where he turns to the camera and he's like, I did it. Like in his face. Oh my God, it's such a great moment, it's perfect. It was a perfect moment. I mean the appreciation, Jenna and I have now in a I think in a deeper way for all the departments of the show that made it come together.
然后转过身看到你们俩都在哭，真的太棒了。我就想，我知道那是最后那一刻，他转向镜头，心想，我做到了。就像他的表情。天哪，这是一个多么棒的时刻，太完美了。这是一个完美的时刻。我的意思是，詹娜和我现在以一种更深的方式感激节目的所有部门，它们让这一切走到了一起。
Mm-hmm, but just really seeing how editors are such beautiful storytellers and you're such a beautiful storyteller. I'm like, Terry, why am I Terry? I don't know. I'm just so appreciative that we all got to work together and that we're still in touch and we get to talk about it. I get this way with every interview. I think all of us went through a lot of stuff in our personal lives during this show.
嗯哼，只是真正看到剪辑师是多么出色的讲故事者，而你就是这样一个出色的讲故事者。我想，特里，为什么我是特里？我不知道。我只是非常感激我们能一起工作，而且我们仍然保持联系，我们还能谈论它。我对每次采访都是这种感觉。我想我们所有人在这部剧期间都在个人生活中经历了很多事情。
And I can't think of somewhere else I'd rather be during that time. Like going through everything, I mean, I can't tell you how supportive you guys were like you two specifically telling me your own personal stories Not even just talking about work just like in life to go through Everyone's gonna face obstacles in life and to have everyone at your side at your work rooting for you And not having to worry about that part of it was just delightful and special. Yeah
而且我想不出在那段时间里还有什么地方比这里更适合我。就像经历这一切，我的意思是，我无法告诉你你们有多支持我，就像你们俩具体跟我分享你们自己的个人故事，甚至不仅仅是谈论工作，就像生活中经历的那样。每个人在生活中都会面临障碍，而在你的工作中有每个人站在你身边为你加油，而不必担心那一部分，这真是太愉快、太特别了。是的
Claire, thank you so much for coming. Yeah. This was such a pleasure. No, this is so much fun. Congratulations on all your insane success. I mean, and you too. I know. My gosh.
克莱尔，非常感谢你的到来。是的。这真是一种荣幸。不，这太有趣了。祝贺你取得的所有疯狂的成功。我的意思是，你也是。我知道。天哪。
Claire's a big ol' badass. Well, we're going to hit you up for questions. Yeah. And upcoming episodes. Sure, sure. Right? Yeah. OK.
克莱尔是个彻头彻尾的狠角色。好吧，我们要向你请教问题。是的。在接下来的剧集中。当然，当然。对吧？是的。好的。
Claire, this was an absolute joy seeing you again. My heart is so full. I just hung on your every word. Thank you so much for taking the time to be here with us today. Yeah, it was amazing. I mean, we chatted for a long time before we even started this interview and I loved all of it. I'm so grateful to both of you.
克莱尔，再次见到你真是太高兴了。我的内心感到无比充实。我简直把你的每一句话都听进去了。非常感谢你今天花时间跟我们在一起。是的，这太棒了。我的意思是，在我们开始这次采访之前，我们聊了很久，我喜欢其中的每一部分。我非常感谢你们俩。
And I feel like I can't leave without saying how welcome you made someone who was like a transfer student at the office because I did come in so deep into the series. You know, I came in halfway through season five. So I never felt like I was, you know, less than or just that, you know, someone writing everyone at the coattails. I always felt so included and in every way, shape, or form, you had an evening where you two treated all the women on the crew out for drinks. Do you remember that? I do, I do.
而且我觉得我不说出来就没法离开，那就是你对待一个像《办公室》里的转学生一样的人是多么热情，因为我加入这个系列的时间真的很深。你知道，我在第五季过半时才加入。所以我从来没有觉得自己，你知道，低人一等，或者只是，你知道，有人在沾光。我总是觉得自己被包容，在任何方面，你们都有一个晚上请了剧组所有的女性出去喝一杯。你还记得吗？我记得，我记得。
That's never happened before since. So that's so special. It was so fun. It was so fun. I'm so glad I wanted to mention that. That's so unique and special. That just doesn't happen. And everyone was so grateful for that.
这在以前或以后都没有发生过。所以这太特别了。太有趣了。太有趣了。我很高兴我想提一下这一点。这太独特、太特别了。这种事根本不会发生。每个人都为此非常感激。
And just to me, it's not just that you did that gesture, it was emblematic of the tone that was set from day one and how it trickled all on down to just such a good bonnami and atmosphere on the entire show. So thank you. Ah! Thanks Claire. Thank you. Well, we're back from break, back from our delightful conversation with Claire, which is still lighting up my heart. Me too. And we're ready to break down this episode. Phyllis is going to arrive to work. It is raining cats and dogs,
对我来说，不仅仅是你们做出了那个举动，它象征着从第一天起就定下的基调，以及它是如何一点点渗透到整个节目中那种良好的人际关系和氛围中的。所以谢谢你。啊！谢谢克莱尔。谢谢。好吧，我们休息回来，从我们与克莱尔的愉快交谈中回来，那段交谈依然点亮着我的心。我也是。我们准备好剖析这一集了。菲利斯要去上班了。外面正下着倾盆大雨，
and I'd like to point out that she has a purple rate coat. Yes. The purple goes beyond her clothing, everyone. It's into her coat, multiple purple accents. Mm-hmm. Jim is gonna say whatever it rains, Phyllis uses the same 12 cliche phrases. And he's promised to order hot chocolates for everyone if she says them all by noon.
我想指出她穿了一件紫色的雨衣。是的。紫色不仅仅局限于她的服装，各位。它进入了她的外套，有多种紫色点缀。嗯哼。吉姆说，无论何时下雨，菲利斯都会使用相同的12个陈词滥调。他承诺如果她在中午之前把它们全说出来，就给每个人点热巧克力。
We got a fan question from Gabriella G and Florida who said, what are all 12 of Phyllis's rainy day cliches? Jim holds them up on a list for a quick second, but it's hard to see, and I would love to be able to get all of the quotes, right? So I can continue to mention them every time it rains. Well, Gabriella, I froze on the quotes, right? So I can continue to mention them every time it rains. Well, Gabriella, I froze on the screen and along with the help of Dunderpedia, who also has the list, we can tell you. Here are Phyllis's 12 phrases. Every time it rains, one, the
我们收到了来自佛罗里达州加布里埃拉·G的粉丝提问，她说，菲利斯的12个雨天陈词滥调都是什么？吉姆把它们在一张纸上举了一小会儿，但很难看清，我很希望能把所有的名言都记下来，对吧？这样每次下雨我都可以继续提到它们。好吧，加布里埃拉，我在屏幕上暂停了，在邓德百科全书的帮助下，它也有这个清单，我们可以告诉你。这里是菲利斯的12个短语。每次下雨，第一，
plants are going to love this. Two, I sure don't want to get stuck in this on the way home. Three, it's raining cats and dogs. Four, the humidity is gonna make my hair freak. Five, the roads are slickest in the first half of the day. Six, I actually sleep better in the rain. Seven, we're paying for all the sun we got this summer. Eight, this weather just makes me want to stay home curled up with a good book. Nine, if we lived in Seattle every day would be like this. Okay. Number 10.
植物会喜欢这个的。第二，我可不想在回家的路上被困在雨里。第三，下着倾盆大调。第四，湿气会让我的头发抓狂。第五，道路在一天的前半段最滑。第六，我其实在雨里睡得更好。第七，我们在为今年夏天享受的所有阳光付出代价。第八，这种天气真让我只想呆在家里蜷缩着看一本好书。第九，如果我们住在西雅图，每天都会是这样。好的。第十。
I wish we were allowed one rain check. Eleven, I love the smell after it rains and 12, nobody knows how to drive in the rain. Those were Phyllis's 12 cliche statements. That's a lot of ground for her to cover to say before noon. Yeah. I was so tickled by this cold open, and I was talking to Josh about it, and he said, and you are Phyllis. I was like, what are you talking about? He said, you always comment on the rain always. And he knew the exact one that I say that Phyllis says, can you guess?
我希望我们能有一次雨天推迟。十一，我喜欢雨后的味道，十二，没有人知道怎么在雨中开车。这些就是菲利斯的12句陈词滥调。她要在中午之前说完这些，内容可真够多的。是的。我对这个冷开场感到非常开心，我和乔希谈过这件事，他说，你就是菲利斯。我说，你在说什么？他说，你总是对雨评头论足，总是这样。而且他知道菲利斯说的那个确切的句子，你能猜到吗？
Oh, let me think. He said, I always say this. The plants are gonna love this. Yes. I always say, all the plants are gonna be so happy. That's what I say. You know, we got more fan mail from this cold open, a fan mail flurry in fact,
哦，让我想想。他说我总是这么说。植物会喜欢这个的。是的。我总是说，所有的植物都会非常高兴。这就是我说的。你知道，我们从这个冷开场收到了更多粉丝来信，事实上是一阵粉丝来信狂潮，
and it all happened at 24 seconds. It's when Phyllis is standing at the water cooler at the very beginning. And I guess she's filling her purple mug, by the way, with water, here's what people said. Not a question, but I need you ladies to see and acknowledge how Phyllis is holding her mug. It kills me every time, and I can't unsee it.
这一切都发生在24秒的时候。当时菲利斯站在最开始的饮水机旁。我想她正在用杯子接水，顺便说一句，她的杯子是紫色的，大家是这么说的。不是问题，但我需要你们这些女士看到并承认菲利斯是怎么拿她的杯子的。每次看到我都快笑死了，而且我挥之不去这个画面。
Other people said, why is Phyllis holding her mug like that? Does she hold her mug like that kills me every time and I can't unsee it. Other people said, why is Phyllis holding her mug like that? Does she hold her mug like that in real life? When you pause the scene, it looks like it's not even her arm holding the mug. I didn't notice it the first time I watched it. Do you have a picture? I didn't. Because I didn't think it was all that strange. I don't know. We can put a picture on the office lady's pod Instagram. She's holding it normally. But a fan male flurry, Angela, like tons of letters.
其他人说，菲利斯为什么要那样拿杯子？她现实生活中也那样拿杯子吗？当你暂停这一幕时，看起来甚至都不是她的胳膊在拿杯子。我第一次看的时候没有注意到。你有照片吗？我没有。因为我并不觉得这有什么奇怪的。我不知道。我们可以把照片发到办公室女郎的播客Instagram上。她拿得很正常。但是一阵粉丝来信狂潮，安吉拉，就像成吨的信件。
This, I wanna know how is everybody else holding their mugs? I don't know, I miss this moment, and now I wanna go back and see it. I'll put it in stories and I'll do a poll. Is she holding it normal or not? I agree. I'll tell you what stories and I'll do a poll. Is she holding it normal or not? I agree. I'll tell you what I did notice at 24 seconds was over Darryl's shoulder, you can see a plaque.
这个，我想知道其他人都是怎么拿杯子的？我不知道，我错过了这一幕，现在我想回去看看。我会把它发到快讯里并做一个投票。她拿得正常还是不正常？我同意。我告诉你我
And it says, in appreciation of dedicated service for Mary Wall, executive assistant to Robert Dunder and Robert Mifflin. And it has a photo of Mary Wall, who was Greg Daniel's assistant. Aw, that's so great. Well, there is an extended producers cut for this episode. If you have the DVD, you will have noticed there are no deleted scenes, just this longer
在24秒时注意到的是在达里尔的肩膀上方，你能看到一块牌匾。上面写着，感谢玛丽·沃尔的奉献服务，她是罗伯特·邓德和罗伯特·米夫林的行政助理。上面还有玛丽·沃尔的照片，她是格雷格·丹尼尔斯的助理。啊，太棒了。好吧，这一集有一个加长的制片人剪辑版。如果你有DVD，你会注意到没有被删减的场景，只有这个更长的
producers cut. And at the end of this cold open, Phyllis doesn't say all of the rain cliches, so they don't get hot chocolate, right? Yeah. And the extended producers Producers cut, the scene goes on one more beat. And Jim decides to get hot chocolate just for Phyllis and him and announces that.
制片人剪辑版。在这个冷开场的结尾，菲利斯并没有说出所有的雨天陈词滥调，所以他们没有得到热巧克力，对吧？是的。在加长的制片人剪辑版中，场景又多了一个节拍。吉姆决定只为菲利斯和他自己买热巧克力，并宣布了这一点。
Oh my gosh, Jenna, you as Pam, your reaction to this is so like what? I didn't remember that. And my reaction as Jenna is the same. What is that about? That's Hugo, you look at him and you're like, ha, it's Kana's act. Like you're so, like ticked off.
哦，天哪，詹娜，你作为帕姆，你对这件事的反应太像“什么？”了。我不记得了。我作为詹娜的反应也是一样的。这算怎么回事？那是休，你看着他，心想，哈，这是卡纳的行为。就像你非常，就像被惹恼了。
I laughed so hard, I rewound it because Pam's expression in this moment just doesn't seem like her at all. Well, I have to say, I feel like it's justified this reaction. I want to say, I feel like it's justified this reaction. I want to put it in stories. It just made me laugh. I just cracked up.
我笑得太厉害了，以至于我倒回去重看了，因为帕姆此刻的表情看起来一点也不像她。好吧，我得说，我觉得这个反应是合乎情理的。我想说，我觉得这个反应是合乎情理的。我想把它发到快讯里。这只是让我大笑。我只是笑喷了。
Clearly Pam loves hot chocolate. That's what I learned. Well, also, what is that? Was Jim rooting against the rest of the office? And then him and Phyllis get hot chocolate, but everybody else doesn't. I thought we were all in it together, Jim. Maybe that's why it's in the extended producer's cut.
显然帕姆很喜欢热巧克力。这就是我了解到的。好吧，还有，那是什么？难道吉姆是在跟办公室的其他人作对吗？然后他和菲利斯买了热巧克力，但其他人却没有。我还以为我们都在一条船上呢，吉姆。也许这就是为什么它在加长的制片人剪辑版里。
And now the episode starts, still no Nelly Bobblehead in the opening credits. No. Nelly little figure there. Andy and Aaron return to the office, they're singing their version of my boyfriend's back. And I thought something was kind of suspicious. Andy says, even though it's the end of the day,
现在剧集开始了，片头字幕里依然没有奈莉的摇头娃娃。没有。奈莉的小玩偶在那里。安迪和艾琳回到办公室，他们唱着他们版本的《我男朋友回来了》。我觉得有些事情有点可疑。安迪说，尽管已经是下班时间了，
they just wanted to stop by and say hello. Why is he in a full suit and tie? And they're showing up at the end of the day. Why is Aaron in tank tops and jeans? I don't understand. I don't understand. I wonder that too. Did they just get back from their drive? And he ran and put on a suit just to come in and say hi. That's such a good point. I know. And then Andy says, hey, Kev, and Kevin's like, yeah, and Andy says, nice sweater. Cause he's wearing Andy's Cornell sweater. Kevin says, thank you.
他们只是想顺便过来打个招呼。为什么他穿着全套西装和领带？他们是在快下班时出现的。为什么艾琳穿着背心和牛仔裤？我不明白。我不明白。我也纳闷。他们刚从兜风回来吗？而他跑去穿上西装只是为了进来打个招呼？这真是个好问题。我懂了。然后安迪说，嘿，凯夫，凯文说，嗯，安迪说，不错的毛衣。因为他穿着安迪的康奈尔毛衣。凯文说，谢谢你。
Nelly was nice enough to give it to me. She's sweet. I just wish there was pockets. Lady, Kevin likes pockets. Yeah, cause you can put things in pockets when you have them. I was like, I guess now for the rest of my life when I hear anyone celebrating pockets, I'm going to think of you. I guess the New Yorker just did a big article about the size of women's pockets.
奈莉很好，把它送给了我。她真好。我只是希望它有口袋。女士，凯文喜欢口袋。是的，因为当你有口袋时，你可以在口袋里放东西。我想，我想从今以后每当我听到有人赞美口袋时，我都会想起你。我想《纽约客》刚刚发表了一篇关于女装口袋大小的大文章。
Everybody said it to me. I saw that. I almost sent it to, but I knew you were traveling. I was like, I'll tell her when I see her. Well, this scene with Andy and Aaron returning was actually longer. It really cracked me up because Andy is trying desperately to tell the office about this romantic gesture he made,
每个人都跟我说了。我看到了。我差一点发给你，但我知道你在旅行。我想，等我见到她时再告诉她。好吧，安迪和艾琳回来的这一幕其实更长。这真的让我笑破肚皮，因为安迪拼命地想向办公室讲述他做出的那个浪漫举动，
driving to Florida to win Aaron over, but everyone keeps interrupting him. And it reminded me of when my husband and I are trying to tell our teenagers a story, but they get stuck on like some tiny detail and they get sidetracked. I want you to hear it. Crazy story. I drove all the way down to Florida. She was not expecting it. Totally swept her off her feet, right? A lot less of drive. It's like a day and a half each way. But when I got there, I went right up to the house and I was like, day and a half, my Lombar would be killing me.
开车去佛罗里达把艾琳赢回来，但每个人都不停地打断他。这让我想起我和我丈夫试图给我们的青少年讲一个故事时，他们却卡在某个微不足道的细节上，然后被岔开了话题。我希望你听听。疯狂的故事。我一路开车到佛罗里达。她完全没有料到。彻底征服了她，对吧？少开很多车。单程大约要一天半。但当我到那儿时，我直接走到房子前，我说，一天半，我的腰椎会受不了的。
Oh, you should get this Lombar support cushion thing. My dad has. What's it called? Not easy rest. That gas must have cost a pretty penny, huh? Well, he's got a Prius. How many times you feel the tank? Three, four.
哦，你应该买那个腰椎支撑垫之类的东西。我爸有一个。叫什么来着？不是Easy Rest吧？那油费一定花了不少钱吧？嗯，他开的是普锐斯。你加满油箱几次？三四次。
What does gas cost down there? Lombar buddy. Lombar buddy. Oh yeah, Lumbar buddy. Tell you what, I'll email you the story. See, I love those moments. They're the small moments, but I just love them. Well, not only is Kevin wearing Andy's Cornell sweater,
那儿的油价多少？伦巴老兄。伦巴老兄。哦对，伦巴老兄。这样吧，我把故事发邮件给你。你看，我喜欢这些时刻。它们虽然是微小的时刻，但我就是喜欢它们。好吧，不仅凯文穿着安迪的康奈尔毛衣，
he sees that Dwight has his fisherman statue old salty on his desk. Mm-hmm. And Dwight says, Oh, yeah, Nelly gave it to him. He turned it into a bobblehead. He's done a bit of an X-Men fan fiction, and he calls it Captain Mutado, half-man half-mermaid. Yeah, so we learned Dwight writes fan fiction,
他还看到德怀特的桌上摆着他那个老水手老咸骨雕像。嗯。德怀特说，哦，对，那是内莉送给他的。他把它改成了一个摇头娃娃。他还搞了点X战警的同人小说，并把它叫做变种人队长，半人半美人鱼。是的，所以我们得知德怀特会写同人小说，
and this made me very curious. Is there a lot of X-Men fan fiction out there? Oh, sure. Oh, lady. I don't know why I know that, but yes. There is a lot. There are many sites. I found one called fanfiction.net And since I was on there looking at X-Men fan fiction, I thought I wonder if this website has the office fanfiction. Well, lady, I know something about the office fanfiction, because it's been sent to me. What? There is a huge amount of Pam Ryan love story fanfiction. Yes, okay, it is. Yes, okay. So on the fanfiction sites, there are several categories, and people can participate, I guess, in the different categories.
这让我非常好奇。外面有很多X战警的同人小说吗？哦，当然。哦，天哪。我不知道为什么我知道这个，但确实有很多。有许多网站。我发现了一个叫fanfiction.net的网站，既然我在上面看X战警的同人小说，我就想，不知道这个网站上有没有《办公室》的同人小说呢。好吧，女士，我对《办公室》的同人小说略知一二，因为有人发给我过。什么？有大量关于帕姆和瑞恩恋爱故事的同人小说。是的，好吧，确实有。是的，好吧。所以在同人小说网站上，有几个类别，我想人们可以参与不同的类别。
Here are a few that made me chuckle. There was a category titled Ryan Slash Pam. Here's the description of it. Here's a collection for all the fans out there for this couple, Ryan Slash Pam. Let me know if you know any other stories that end with this pairing. So the whole show plays out and Ryan and Pam end up together. Yeah. Beige and I have talked about this. It's a very, very popular threat. It's hilarious. Which is funny because in this episode, Pam flat out tells Ryan, I have
这里有几个让我忍不住笑出来的。有一个类别叫做“瑞恩杠帕姆”。以下是它的描述：这里是为所有喜欢这对情侣（瑞恩杠帕姆）的粉丝们收集的作品。如果你知道任何其他以这对组合结尾的故事，请让我知道。所以整部剧演下来，瑞恩和帕姆最终走到了一起。是的，贝杰和我讨论过这个。这是一个非常非常热门的威胁。太搞笑了。这就很有趣，因为在这集里，帕姆直截了当地告诉瑞恩：“我从未
never liked you. I feel like I said that clear. Yeah. She's like, you're not a good person. Here was another one I thought was cute. This category was titled, Wicca Wicca Wicca What? And it says, a collection of Michael slash Holly stories because even though Holly left Scranton we're not ready to let her go. Aw!
喜欢过你。”我觉得我把话说得很清楚了。对。她就像在说，你不是个好人。还有一个我觉得很可爱的。这个类别叫做“威卡威卡威卡什么鬼？”，上面写着：迈克尔杠霍利的故事合集，因为尽管霍利离开了斯克兰顿，我们还没准备好让她走。啊！
Then there was one called Monkey and D, a Dewey Angela community featuring everyone's favorite secret couple from the office. In the words of our Queen Angela, office relationships are nobody's business, but the people involved. And lastly, this one really cracked me up. There was a category named Team Toby,
然后还有一个叫“猴子与D”，一个杜威和安吉拉的社群，主角是大家在《办公室》里最喜欢的秘密情侣。用我们女王安吉拉的话说，办公室恋情不关别人的事，除了当事人。最后，这个真的把我逗乐了。有一个类别叫“托比战队”，
the ultimate archive for fan fiction about or directly featuring Toby Flindersen. For everyone who stayed on the team, despite season four's little trip to quote, fence leaping crazy town, because who needs love more than everyone's least favorite HR rep? It's so funny. I didn't know about fanfiction until I started getting sent the Pam Ryan thing. Yeah. And B.J. and I were talking about it. I guess it's like, in the same way that you might have a historical fiction novel where you write something fictional,
这是关于或直接以托比·弗林德森为主角的同人小说的终极档案。献给所有留在战队里的粉丝，尽管第四季经历了一场被称为“跳篱笆的疯狂小镇”的小风波，因为谁比大家最讨厌的人力资源代表更需要爱呢？太搞笑了。我以前不知道同人小说，直到我开始收到帕姆和瑞恩的作品。是的。贝杰和我当时在讨论这个。我想这就好像，就像你可能会有一部历史小说，你写一些虚构的东西，
but based on history, they take the characters from the office and then they write fiction about us. I mean, I didn't read any of the actual pieces, but just the titles of the categories were cracking me up. Well, some of them can get very racy. Oh, I bet. Mm-hmm. Did I sound like your elderly aunt when I said that?
但以历史为基础，他们把《办公室》里的角色拿来，然后写关于我们的虚构故事。我的意思是，我没有读过任何实际的作品，但光是类别名称就把我逗乐了。嗯，其中有些内容可能会非常火辣。哦，我敢打赌。嗯。我说这话的时候听起来像你老姑妈吗？
Yeah, yeah. They can get real racy. They can get very, you know, scantilists. Okay. So Andy's going to enter his office, which is now Nelly's office. We talked about that with Claire. And they're going to start this high-noons standoff, and he says, you know what, he would like his office back, and Nelly says, no. Well, lady, in the producer's cut,
对，对。它们可能会变得真的很火辣。它们可能会变得非常，你知道的，香艳。好吧。所以安迪要走进他的办公室，现在那是内莉的办公室了。我们和克莱尔聊过这个。他们要开始一场正午决斗，他说，你知道吗，他想要回他的办公室，内莉说，不。好吧，女士，在制片人剪辑版中，
there is a scene where Andy marches in and talks to Robert in the conference room. And this really cracked me up because Robert calls him out for just abruptly leaving for Florida without giving notice or explanation. And then not answering his phone, he just was absent. So Robert confronts him and Andy says, I had to tell Aaron how I felt. And here's the speech I love. Robert says, Andy, I appreciate your romantic quest. And in an age before the telephone, or internet, or written language, that would be compelling. But there are five, six devices in this room alone that would have let you tell her that
有一个场景是安迪气冲冲地走进去，在会议室里和罗伯特谈话。这真的把我逗乐了，因为罗伯特指责他突然动身去弗吉尼亚，连招呼都不打，也没有任何解释或说明。然后不接电话，直接失踪了。所以罗伯特质问他，安迪说，我必须告诉艾琳我的感受。我最喜欢这段演讲了。罗伯特说，安迪，我很赞赏你的浪漫追求。在电话、互联网或书面语言出现之前的时代，那会很有吸引力。但仅在这个房间里就有五、六个设备，能让你在不去弗吉尼亚的情况下把那些话告诉她。
without going to Florida. We live in amazing times. All of that was so funny to me. I loved really hard. It was like, but in an age before the telephone. Or the written word I know. And then after this scene, Andy is pretty upset. And Aaron walks him out to the car and says,
我们生活在一个神奇的时代。所有这些对我来说都太搞笑了。我笑得好厉害。就像是，但在电话出现之前的时代。或者书面文字，我知道。然后在这场戏之后，安迪非常沮丧。艾琳把他送到车旁说，
don't worry, we're going to have a hot date tonight. So you can really see where Andy's minds at. You know, he doesn't have his head in the game here. And while all that's going on, Pam and Jim are in the kitchen with Kelly and Ravi. Yes, Ravi was played by Centil Ramma Murphy. He was very famous for starring in all four seasons of the NBC sci-fi drama Heroes.
别担心，我们今晚会有个火热的约会。所以你真的能看出安迪的心思在哪里。你知道的，他现在根本没把心思放在正事上。与此同时，帕姆和詹姆在厨房里和凯莉以及拉维在一起。是的，拉维由森蒂尔·拉玛穆西饰演。他因主演NBC科幻剧《英雄》四季而非常知名。
He was also in Heroes Reborn. A little fun fact about his role in Heroes. It was originally written for a 55-year-old man, but his audition was so good that he ended up getting a screen test, and then they rewrote the role for him. He was very good in Heroes. Yeah. Yeah. He also recently starred in Mindy's show Never Have I Ever.
他也出演了《英雄重生》。关于他在《英雄》中的角色有一个趣事。这个角色原本是为一个55岁的男人写的，但他的试镜表现太棒了，以至于他最终得到了银幕测试机会，然后他们为他重写了这个角色。他在《英雄》里演得非常好。对。对。他最近还主演了敏迪的剧《好想做一次》。
He was so handsome. He was very handsome. Very, very handsome. And very, very good. And he really gets under Ryan's skin. Ryan doesn't like Robbie. He has to pop out of his closet. And he wants in on this conversation.
他太帅了。他非常帅。非常非常帅。而且非常非常好。他真的让瑞恩很不爽。瑞恩不喜欢罗比。他不得不从他的壁橱里跳出来。而且他想加入这个对话。
Robbie is Jim and Pam's pediatrician. He's giving Jim and Pam a little advice about cycling baby Phillips legs to help with gas. And Ryan wants you to know that you shouldn't shake a baby. Right. There are some great bloopers from this because Ryan popping out suddenly to tell Jim and Pam not to shake the baby. We did a lot of improving around
罗比是詹姆和帕姆的儿科医生。他给詹姆和帕姆提供了一些建议，关于做蹬自行车动作来帮助小菲利普缓解胀气。而瑞恩想让你知道，你不能摇晃婴儿。对。这里有一些非常棒的NG镜头，因为瑞恩突然跳出来告诉詹姆和帕姆不要摇晃婴儿。我们围绕这个建议做了很多即兴发挥。
this advice. There was one point when I think Jim said, do you have a medical degree or something? No, just all made us laugh, but it's very, very funny. Well, there's a lot of Pam's ass that happens here. There is. Yeah. She's like, oh, don't shake the baby. Thanks, Ryan. Thanks for the hot tip. BJ Novak said that the character of Ravi was brought in to give the character of Kelly a reason to quit Dunder Mifflin at the end of the season because she was leaving to do the Mindy Project.
有一次，我想詹姆说，你是有医学学位还是怎么着？不，只是这把我们都逗笑了，但真的非常非常搞笑。嗯，这里有很多帕姆的屁股戏。确实。是的，她就像，哦，别摇晃婴儿。谢谢你，瑞恩。谢谢你的好建议。B·J·诺瓦克说，引入拉维这个角色是为了给凯莉在季终离开邓德米弗林一个理由，因为她要离开去拍《敏迪项目》。
Aw. So that's why we introduced the storyline of Kelly and Ravi. I also have a fan catch from the scene from Aiden W. and Portland, Oregon, who said, when the camera cuts to Ryan in his closet, next to him over his shoulder is a jar of jumbo pretzels, but they are all broken. Who would buy it? Or did Phil Shae purposely break all the pretzels? It's driving me crazy!
啊。所以这就是我们引入凯莉和拉维这条故事线的原因。我还收到了来自俄勒冈州波特兰市的艾登·W的粉丝抓包，他说，当镜头切到瑞恩在衣橱里时，他旁边肩膀上方有一罐特大号蝴蝶饼，但它们全碎了。谁会买这个？还是菲尔·谢伊故意把所有蝴蝶饼都弄碎了？这快把我逼疯了！
That is such a specific detail. Yeah! Once I saw it, I couldn't unsee it, Angela. And I had a memory of why the pretzels are broken and let me ask you if you have the same memory. Okay. When we would stand in the kitchen for group scenes sometimes, the guys would open it up and break the pretzels. Do you remember this? Like just as like something to cure boredom. I remember them doing this. I remember them breaking the pretzels.
这是一个非常具体的细节。是的！一旦我看到了，我就再也无法忽视它了，安吉拉。我有记忆记起为什么蝴蝶饼会碎，让我问问你是否有同样的记忆。好吧。有时当我们站在厨房拍群戏时，男生们会打开它然后把蝴蝶饼捏碎。你记得这个吗？就像是用来消磨无聊时光一样。我记得他们这么干过。我记得他们把蝴蝶饼捏碎了。
I mean, I, oh my God. Because we wouldn't eat them. No, because they were sprayed with stuff like those cheese balls we found that out. It was like a weird sensory boredom thing. Do you remember this? I so remember it now. As you're saying it, I'm like, I kind of remember them kind of mucking around. Oh my gosh. Did they? That's crazy. Yes. We also got a fan catch from Dakota T in Tennessee who said, when we're introduced to Ravi, played by Centil Ramamurthy, who also was in the show
我是说，我，哦天哪。因为我们不会吃它们。不，因为它们被喷了东西，就像我们发现的那些奶酪球一样。这就像是一种奇怪的感官无聊行为。你记得这个吗？经你这么一说我太想起来了。当你这么说的时候，我想，我有点记得他们在那儿瞎胡闹。哦天哪。他们真的这么干了？太疯狂了。是的。我们还收到了田纳西州达科他·T的粉丝抓包，他说，当我们认识由森蒂尔·拉玛穆西饰演的拉维时，他也出演了《英雄》这部剧，
heroes, I want to point out that in an earlier episode, the negotiation, I think Dwight mentions hero Nakamura from heroes, which means the show exists in Dwight's life on the office wouldn't Dwight have recognized Ravi from heroes. I wish I wish there was a moment where he walked by and did a double take like hmm yeah. This was when we sort of gave up on the fact that people were well known for other shows. Ryan actually ends up going up to Jim and Pam because he wants more info on this situation because it seems like this guy is really into Kelly. And Ryan would rather Kelly be alone than be with somebody
我想指出的是，在早前的一集《谈判》中，我想德怀特提到了《英雄》中的中村英雄，这意味着这部剧存在于《办公室》中德怀特的生活里，难道德怀特不会从《英雄》中认出拉维吗？我希望，我希望有一个场景是他走过时回头看了一眼，就像，嗯，是的。这就是我们有点放弃“人们因为其他剧集而广为人知”这个设定的时候。瑞恩实际上最终走向詹姆和帕姆，因为他想要关于这种情况的更多信息，因为看起来这家伙非常迷恋凯莉。而且瑞恩宁愿凯莉单身也不愿她和别人在一起，
even though they weren't right together. And then he's like, is this love? Oh my gosh, Pam's looked to Ryan. Yeah. Well now Robert and Andy are gonna go into Nellie's office and Robert's gonna say, listen, you know, you've been great, but Andy is the manager.
尽管他们自己并没有真正合适。然后他问，这就是爱吗？哦天哪，帕姆看着瑞恩的眼神。是的。现在罗伯特和安迪要走进内莉的办公室，罗伯特会说，听着，你知道的，你一直很棒，但安迪才是经理。
And Nelly's like, no, this throws Robert for a loop. He says he is not used to being told no. And then Nelly is very flirty with him and she's like, get used to it because it's gonna feel so good. And someone says, yes, there's something like, no, that's what she says. She plays it on pretty thick.
而内莉却说，不，这让罗伯特大吃一惊。他说他不习惯被人拒绝。然后内莉对他说了很多调情的话，她说，习惯它吧，因为这感觉太棒了。然后有人说，是的，有类似的话，不，她是这么说的。她演得相当露骨。
Yeah. And Robert has a talking head where he says he doesn't normally allow sexual desire to influence his business decisions, but he finds it best to temporarily recuse himself until he's made love. And then he can revisit the situation rationally. He says, Buffett operates the same way. Okay. I have found the character of Robert California just gets increasingly weirder and weirder.
是的。罗伯特有一个单人独白，他说他通常不允许性欲影响他的商业决策，但他发现最好暂时回避，直到他做爱之后。然后他可以理性地重新审视这种情况。他说，巴菲特也是这样运作的。好吧。我发现罗伯特·加利福尼亚这个角色变得越来越古怪了。
And I got a little curious about it, like what exactly is going on? Why? And I actually found a quote from James Spader in Andy Green's book. And I wanna read you his take on Robert California. Getting weirder and weirder. Great.
我对此有点好奇，到底是怎么回事？为什么？我实际上在安迪·格林的书中找到了詹姆斯·斯派德的一句名言。我想读给你听听他对罗伯特·加利福尼亚的看法。变得越来越古怪。太棒了。
He said, quote, the characters on the show were constantly treating my character like this sort of enigmatic guy who they couldn't quite figure out. And I realized partway in that the writers couldn't quite figure him out either. I mean, the same relationship that the other characters had with Robert, the writers had with him as well. But I feel that worked to my advantage. They wrote some really strange eccentric stuff
他说，引述如下：“剧中的角色经常把我的角色当作这种神秘莫测的家伙，他们怎么也琢磨不透。我中途意识到，编剧们也怎么琢磨不透他。我的意思是，其他角色对罗伯特的这种关系，编剧们对他也是一样的。但我觉这为我带来了优势。他们写了一些非常奇怪、古怪的东西，
that I loved goofing around with. Now, whether it was successful in terms of the greater context of the whole show, I don't know. That wasn't my concern. My concern was to try and play this guy and commit to him. And to me, he was just this very strange, totally eccentric and agbatic guy. And I me, he was just this very strange, totally eccentric
我非常喜欢拿它们来胡闹。现在，就整部剧的宏观背景而言它是否成功，我不知道。那不是我关心的。我关心的是试着扮演这个家伙并全身心投入。对我来说，他只是这个非常奇怪、完全古怪和狂喜的家伙。而我认为这确实在他的表演中展现出来了。这也是我对他的记忆。他就是那种演员，你在剧院里经常能找到这种演员。剧作家写的台词就是法律。作为演员，你的工作就是想方设法让它行得通。你让它行得通。我只是，我真的很喜欢对这个角色的这种看法，以及他对所分配到的角色有什么可玩的。是的，我也喜欢那样。好吧，既然罗伯特已经离开，现在内莉和安迪的对决真的要上演了。我们和克莱尔聊过这个。他们开始你来我往，她叫安吉拉扣他的工资，安吉拉就像立刻照办。
and ecstatic guy. And I think that really comes out in his performance. And it's what I remember of him. He's one of those actors and you find them a lot in the theater. The words that the playwright has written are the law. And it's your job as the actor to figure out how to make it work. And you make it work. And I just, I really liked that perspective on the character and what he had to say about what he was given to play with. Yeah, I like that too. Well, since Robert has left, now the Nelly Andy showdown is really going to happen. And we talked about this with Claire. They start going back and forth where she calls on Angela to dock his pay and Angela's like on it.
然后安迪想让安吉拉扣内莉的工资。她没有回应。一片寂静。一片寂静。最后内莉威胁要扣安迪一万美元工资。她开始数数。安迪仓皇离开。
And then Andy wants Angela to dock Nellie's pay. She doesn't respond. Crickets. Crickets. And then ultimately Nellie's gonna threaten to dock Andy's pay $10,000. She starts counting. Andy leaves heredly.
是的。他找了个借口。拍摄剧本里写着他得去嘘嘘。哦，他溜出了房间。我明白了。好吧，艾琳会陪着一个备受打击的安迪走到车旁。嗯。我不知道你有没有注意到，外面的地面是湿的。他们在车上洒了雨滴。因为你知道的，开场白。是的。雨已经停了，但之前下得很大，倾盆大雨。我有点觉得艾琳在这里应该看懂眼色，虽然你看，我知道艾琳不太懂看眼色。
Yeah. He makes up an excuse. It's in the shooting draft that he has to pee. Oh, he ducks out of the room. I see. Well, Aaron's gonna walk a very deflated Andy to the car. Mm-hmm. And I don't know if you noticed, but the ground outside is wet. And they had sprinkled rain drops on the car. Because you know the cold open. Yes. It had stopped raining, but it was raining earlier, cats and dogs. I kind of feel like Aaron should have read the room here, which look, I know Aaron doesn't read the room well.
但我觉得她本应该说，你知道的，忘掉今晚的火热约会吧。对，你知道的，今天发生了太多事。我看得出你心事重重。咱们就随便待着吧。咱们看个电影吧。但我觉得，难道这不正是女人在辛苦了一天后可能想要的吗？
But I think she should have been like, you know, forget about tonight's hot date. Right, you know, a lot happened today. I can see you're preoccupied. Let's just hang out. Let's just watch a movie. But I feel like isn't that kind of maybe what a woman wants at the end of a hard day
希望她的伴侣能够理解，就像我知道你会喜欢的是在沙发上好好依偎一下，然后我们狂刷一部剧，分享一桶冰淇淋那种感觉。但也许对于一个辛苦了一天的男人来说，我知道，我现在在抛出刻板印象，也许男人更想要火热的约会。你知道我的意思吗？辛苦了一天的男人喜欢怎么结束他们的一天？
is for her partner to recognize like I know what you would love is a good snuggle on the couch and let's binge a show and share a tub of ice cream sort of thing. But maybe at the end of the hard day for a man, I know, I'm throwing out stereotypes right now that maybe the man wants the hot day. You know what I mean? How do men who've had a hard day like to finish their day?
我确信他们会留着那个火热的约会。他们会写信告诉我们的。好吧，在播出的那一集中，下一个场景是新的一天开始。对吧？是艾琳在休息室里接近安迪。好吧，在制片人剪辑版中，在此之前还有一个场景。哦，我想分享一下。安迪缩在仓库的拐角处，有点躲在那条小巷里。当德怀特、凯文和奥斯卡走进来开始新的一天时，他就像，伙计们，伙计们，他把他们拉到一边。我想让你听听这段剪辑。
I'm sure they'll sit with the hot day. They'll write us and let us know. Okay, so in the episode that aired, the next scene is the start of a new day. Right? It's Aaron approaching Andy in the break room. Well, in the producer's cut, there was a scene before it. Oh, and I want to share it. Andy is sort of tucked around the corner of the warehouse, kind of hiding in that alleyway. And as Dwight Kevin and Oscar make their way in for the day, he's like, guys, guys, and he pulls them aside. And I want you to hear this clip.
你们在聊什么？查理·罗斯。我不知道那是谁。伙计们，他有人选。过来。你们在，快点。我们要去哪？好吧。你们想加入安迪吗？你不应该站在那儿。仓库的人总在那儿小便。
What are you guys talking about? Charlie Rose. I don't know who that is. Guys, he has guys. Come here. What do you, come on. Where are we going? OK. Do you guys want Andy? You should not stand there. The warehouse guys pee there all the time.
你。好吧。你们想成为伟大事业的一部分吗？我已经加入了一个最大的俱乐部。不经常去教堂的基督徒。还记得电影《鲁迪》里，一个球员走进教练办公室，
You. Okay. Do you guys want to be part of something huge? I'm already a member of the largest club there is. Non-Churchgoing Christians. You remember in the movie Rudy when a player comes into the coach's office Any member of the largest club there is? Non-church-going Christians. You remember in the movie Rudy when a player comes into the coach's office and throws his jersey down and he's like, I'm not playing without Rudy. And the coach is like, one guy, no big deal.
任何不经常去教堂的基督徒？还记得电影《鲁迪》里，一个球员走进教练办公室，把球衣往地上一摔，说，没有鲁迪我不踢了。教练说，一个人而已，没大不了的。
But then every player comes in one by one and they all throw their jerseys down for Rudy. You remember that? Yeah, I remember that. So how amazing would it be if you guys all did that for me with your own brand new Dunder Mifflin jerseys. Hey guys. And then Nate comes in and starts to pee by the wall. What's so amazing about that is they made Dunder Mifflin jerseys? Yes, for the scene, a whole box of them. He holds them up. They're like legit, nice, real like football jerseys. They're navy and in white they say Dunder Mifflin. I wish I had one. Yeah, they're so cute. And
但接着每个球员一个接一个地走进来，为了鲁迪把他们的球衣都摔在地上。你记得那个吗？对，我记得那个。所以，如果你们所有人也用你们崭新的邓德米弗林球衣为我做这件事，那该有多棒啊。嘿，伙计们。然后内特走进来，开始在墙边小便。最神奇的是，他们竟然做了邓德米弗林球衣？是的，为了这个场景，整整一箱。他把它们举起来。它们就像是正宗的、漂亮的、真正的美式橄榄球球衣。它们是海军蓝的，上面用白色写着邓德米弗林。我真希望我有一件。是的，它们太可爱了。而且，
lady, I just thought, you know, we had these jerseys made and the storyline got completely cut. But you can see them throughout the episode. I'm going to point them out. Starting with when Aaron approaches Andy in the break room to say, hey, you know what, don't worry about last night. It wasn't a big deal. We were both tired, right? She's doing that whole speech.
女士，我当时想，你知道的，我们让人做了这些球衣，结果这条故事线被完全剪掉了。但你可以在整集中看到它们。我要把它们指出来。从艾琳在休息室接近安迪说，嘿，你知道吗，别担心昨晚的事。那没什么大不了的。我们都很累，对吧？她说了整段台词。
Andy is going through the big box of jerseys. Oh my gosh, that's what that was. Yes. He ultimately hands the jerseys out to everyone. I'll point that out later. I think it's really weird that Aaron waited until the break room to bring up last night. I didn't want to talk about that on the drive-in. I know.
安迪正在翻找那大箱球衣。哦天哪，原来那是这个意思。是的。他最终把球衣分发给每个人。我稍后会指出这一点。我觉得艾琳等到在休息室才提起昨晚的事真的很奇怪。我才不想在开车来的路上谈论这个呢。我知道。
Or anywhere. Yeah, before work. Yeah. Andy leaves the break, before work. Yeah. Andy leaves the break room and he's angry. We're kind of seeing angry Andy for the first time. Well, Aaron won't drop it. Yeah. They sort of got past it, but then she's like, again, it's no big deal.
或者在任何地方。对，在工作前。是的。安迪离开休息室时很生气。我们算是第一次看到生气的安迪。好吧，艾琳就是不肯罢休。是的。他们本来已经把这事抛在脑后了，但她又说，再说一次，这真的没什么大不了的。
And it's like, okay, how many times are you going to say it's no big deal when it's clearly a big deal? Ryan's going to try to woo Kelly back by showing her photos of himself that he made her take of him while they were in a fight. Yeah. Aaron's gonna seek out some advice from Dwight they sneak off to the stairwell
这就好像，好吧，当这明显是一件大事时，你要说多少次这没什么大不了的？瑞恩要通过向凯莉展示他在他们吵架时让她给自己拍的照片来重新追求凯莉。是的。艾琳要去找德怀特寻求一些建议，他们溜进楼梯间，
where you have a private conversation in the world of Dunder Bifflin and she wants to know if he ever experienced penal softiosis when he was manager. He's like absolutely not. No, never happened. I felt like rain improvised at the end because sometimes he would love to improvise
在那里你们在邓德米弗林的世界里进行了一场私密的谈话，她想知道他当经理时是否经历过阴茎软化症。他说绝对没有。不，从没发生过。我觉得雷恩最后是即兴发挥的，因为有时他很喜欢即兴发挥，
as you were leaving a scene, kind of shout something out to you. Okay, so I went to the shooting draft and he did. He improvised the Washington Monument and the Eiffel Tower and there was a third one that made it in the extended cut that was not in the aired version where he said, and Colossus at Rhodes. And then there was a brief little moment in the extended cut where Pam says to Kelly, hey, do you want a shop instead of having lunch today? And Kelly flips out. She's like, seriously? And that's when the scene starts of the two of them
就像你离开一个场景时，朝你大喊点什么。好吧，我去查了拍摄剧本，他确实这么做了。他即兴提到了华盛顿纪念碑和埃菲尔铁塔，还有一个加长版里保留但在播出版中没有的第三个，他说，还有罗德岛巨像。然后在加长版里有一个简短的片段，帕姆对凯莉说，嘿，今天不吃午饭，你想去购物吗？凯莉崩溃了。她就像，认真的吗？然后就接上两人开始
online shopping. It was Pam's invitation. Pam's plotting. She's working it. Oh, I like that. Well, I remember the very top of the scene got cut because what's happening at the very beginning of the scene is Kelly is buying every item in every color and every size. And Pam says you're buying every color and every size. And Kelly says it's free returns. And then the scene would have picked up. Yes.
网上购物的场景。那是帕姆的邀请。帕姆在密谋。她在搞事情。哦，我喜欢那样。嗯，我记得这个场景的最开头被剪掉了，因为场景一开始发生的是凯莉把每种颜色、每个尺寸的每件商品都买了下来，帕姆说你把每种颜色和尺寸都买了，凯莉说可以免费退货。然后场景就会接着往下演。是的。
Well Pam is trying to remind Kelly of how unhappy she was with Ryan. She's like, don't you remember when he cheated on you? And she's like, which time? Pam's looks to camera were very good. Well Pam is a talking head. She is not going to let Kelly throw her life away for Ryan. And also, this has nothing to do with her access to her pediatrician. She feels like that question was coming.
帕姆在试图提醒凯莉她和瑞恩在一起时有多不快乐。她就像，你不记得他背叛你的时候了吗？她就像，哪一次？帕姆对镜头的眼神非常到位。好吧，帕姆有一个单人独白。她不会让凯莉为了瑞恩而毁掉自己的人生。而且，这与她找儿科医生的途径没有任何关系。她觉得那个问题就要来了。
She doesn't know why. She felt like it was. I thought you were really funny in this episode, Jenna. I really enjoyed your performance. I really liked this B story. I really liked going head to head with Ryan. I love doing scenes with Mindy. Well clearly the fans love it when Pam and Ryan go head to head. I guess that's the fan fiction site. We'll show you. There's now a scene in Nellie's office where Dwight is running down a list of things
她不知道为什么。她觉得会是这样。我觉得你在这一集里真的很好笑，珍娜。我很享受你的表演。我很喜欢这条B故事线。我很喜欢和瑞恩正面交锋。我喜欢和敏迪演对手戏。显然粉丝们很喜欢帕姆和瑞恩正面交锋。我想那就是同人小说网站的功劳。我们会让你知道的。现在内莉的办公室里有一个场景，德怀特正在宣读一件正在公司里发生的事情的清单。
that are going on around the office. Here's how it read in the script. Pam sent around a puppy clip that most found overrated. I think one of Toby's eyes is getting smaller. Gabe bragged about having an extra ticket to an air show this weekend. Meredith expressed interest.
剧本里是这样写的：帕姆传阅了一个小狗短片，大多数人觉得被高估了。我觉得托比的一只眼睛越来越小了。加比吹嘘说他这个周末有一张航展的额外票。梅雷迪思表示感兴趣。
Gabe then said his friend might be taking the ticket. I'll keep you posted. Then he's going to spill the beans about Andy's impotence. Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm. And I think we should take a break, because Nelly's gonna call a whole conference room meeting about it. Yeah.
加比接着说他的朋友可能要那张票。我会随时向你们通报。然后他要说漏嘴关于安迪阳痿的事。嗯。嗯。我觉得我们应该休息一下，因为内莉要为此召开一个全公司会议。是的。
A really awkward conference room scene about it. I was legitimately uncomfortable. I felt so bad room scene about it. I was legitimately uncomfortable. I felt so bad for Andy. Same. All right, we'll talk all about it in a minute. On that note. [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ We are back.
一个非常尴尬的关于这件事的会议室场景。我真的感到很不舒服。我为安迪感到难过会议室场景。我真的感到很不舒服。我为安迪感到难过。我也是。好吧，我们一会儿再详细聊。伴随着这个。[♪ 片尾曲播放 [♪ 我们回来了。
Nelly is going to call a conference room meeting. And Andy's like, no, he pretends to call the conference room meeting, right? Because she's not the manager. Go to 10 minutes, 34 seconds. You can see a box of jerseys. And there's a few kind of around the office. You can see one plainly on the file cabinet by Dwight's desk. That's because there was a scene where Andy was still trying
内莉要召开一个会议室会议。安迪就像，不，他假装要召开会议室会议，对吧？因为她不是经理。去到10分34秒。你可以看到一箱球衣。办公室周围还有几个。你可以在德怀特桌子旁的文件柜上清楚地看到一件。那是因为有一个场景是安迪还在试图
to get everyone to get on board with this Rudy idea. There's a whole scene in the extended cut where they're like passing out jerseys. They're talking about the movie. And then Jim says what about Spartacus? It's a whole thing. Well, Andy's going to look over his shoulder and he sees the word importance written on the whiteboard.
让所有人接受这个鲁迪的想法。加长版里有一整场戏，他们在大发球衣。他们谈论这部电影。然后詹姆说那斯巴达克斯呢？这是一整套东西。好吧，安迪回过头去，他看到白板上写着“重要”这个词。
And he's like, yes, this is about how everyone in the room is important. And Robert corrects him. Robert says it doesn't say importance. Andy, it says impotence. You know what I thought? What? Sometimes we see what we need to see. Oh!
他就像，是的，这是关于房间里的每个人都很重要。罗伯特纠正了他。罗伯特说上面没写重要，安迪，写的是阳痿。你知道我在想什么吗？什么？有时我们看到的是我们所需要看到的。哦！
He needed to feel important. Yeah. Sorry, he didn't mean to be the sad aunt that points things out. Nelly's going to take over the conference room meeting now, and she's going to explain that impotence is a human problem. And everyone starts weighing in. Yeah Dwight says not necessarily a human problem. Flaounders also experienced this when converting from one gender to another. Mm-hmm. Had to know. Did Dwight make this up? Are some of it truth?
他需要觉得自己很重要。是的。对不起，他不是故意当那个指出问题的伤心姑妈的。内莉现在要接管会议室会议了，她要解释阳痿是一个人类问题。每个人都开始发表意见。是的，德怀特说不一定是个人类问题。比目鱼在从一种性别转换为另一种性别时也会经历这个。嗯。不得不了解。这是德怀特瞎编的吗？还是部分是事实？
I almost looked it up and I didn't and I'm so glad you did because it's bothered me that I don't know. This is classic Dwight, you guys, where he says something and there's always a little bit of truth, even though sometimes it sounds bizarre. I found an article titled, Hookline in Science. I like it already, and it had this to say about flounders. New research shows that higher temperatures can mask colonize southern flounder populations.
我差点去查了，但我没查，我太高兴你查了，因为我不知道这一点一直让我很纠结。这就是典型的德怀特，伙计们，他说话总是带有一点点真实性，尽管有时听起来很离奇。我找到了一篇文章，标题叫《科学钓鱼法》。我一听就喜欢上了，关于比目鱼它是这么说的：最新研究表明，较高的温度可以掩盖南部比目鱼种群的性别分化。
For many reptiles and some fishes, their sex can be determined by the temperatures in their surrounding environment. Southern flounder exhibits this temperature-dependent sex determination when exposed to warm, or cool temperatures during a critical period in juvenile development and can cause genetic females to develop as males. But then are they impotent? Well, I put an asterisk and said it doesn't mention anything about impotence. Well, we learned
对于许多爬行动物和一些鱼类来说，它们的性别可以由其周围环境的温度决定。南部比目鱼在幼年发育的关键时期暴露于温暖或寒冷温度下时，会表现出这种温度依赖性的性别决定，并可能导致遗传上的雌性发育为雄性。但它们阳痿吗？好吧，我加了个星号说文章里没提到任何关于阳痿的事。好吧，我们了解了
some very interesting things about flounders. But I said I guess Dwight is half right. Yeah, okay. I said I guess Dwight is half right. Yeah, okay. Very interesting. Oscar is gonna ask if the person in quotes experiencing the impotence would like everyone to help her. And Nelly says, no, no, no, it's not me. It's not me. She says that Dwight spoke with her about impotence. And I guess Dwight is gonna prove to everyone that no, it's not him. He can get an erection on the spot. Everyone is completely grossed out and tells him to sit down. And that's when Andy finally confesses. Look, I had a little problem with Aaron last night. Then this cuts to an Andy talking head and he's like, hey, I had a lot on my mind.
一些关于比目鱼的非常有趣的事情。但我说我猜德怀特有一半是对的。好吧，好吧。我猜德怀特有一半是对的。好吧，好吧。非常有趣。奥斯卡要问那个引号里的经历阳痿的人是否希望大家帮帮她。内莉说，不，不，不，不是我。不是我。她说德怀特和她谈过关于阳痿的事。我想德怀特要向大家证明，不，不是他。他可以当场勃起。每个人都感到极其恶心，让他坐下。就在那时安迪终于承认了。听着，我昨晚跟艾琳出了点小问题。然后镜头切到一个安迪的单人独白，他就像，嘿，我当时满脑子都是事。
Happens to plenty of guys. It's usually not followed up by a workplace discussion, and I agree. Yeah. Yeah, we don't need to bring this to work. We don't need to bring this to work. The scene's going to continue. Everyone is now chiming in.
很多男人都会遇到。这通常不会紧接着来一场职场讨论，我同意。是的。是的，我们没必要把这带到工作中来。我们没必要把这带到工作中来。场景将继续。每个人现在都在七嘴八舌。
But did anyone else notice when St. Louis showed up at 24 minutes and 46 seconds? A lady, Katie J. from Edmond, Oklahoma, but who was born in St. Louis, sure, Katie J from Edmund, Oklahoma, but who was born in St. Louis, sure did. Hey Edmund, Oklahoma, I've been there. Just a shout out. Well, Phyllis says, if it makes you feel any better, I never had an orgasm until I was farty too. And then when I did, it lasted until I was farty far.
但有没有人注意到森蒂尔在24分46秒出现时？来自俄克拉荷马州埃德蒙的凯蒂·J，但出生在圣路易斯，当然，来自俄克拉荷马州埃德蒙的凯蒂·J，但出生在圣路易斯，当然注意到了。嘿，俄克拉荷马州埃德蒙，我去过那儿。打个招呼。好吧，菲利斯说，如果这能让你感觉好受点，我直到42岁才经历过高潮。然后当我体验到时，它一直持续到了44岁。
Exactly. Did I do it okay? You did very well. Thank you. Yes, Katie J said that listening to Phyllis say this line it lasted till I was farty far. Exactly. Did I do it okay? You did very well. Thank you. Yes, Katie J said that listening to Phyllis say this line made her want to head straight up farty far and get some Ted Drew's, because that is the free way that you take to get to the famous Ted Drew's Frozen Custard. Farty far.
没错。我演得还可以吧？你演得很好。谢谢。是的，凯蒂·J说听着菲利斯说这句台词“它一直持续到了44岁”，这让她想直接去44号公路买些泰德德鲁斯的冷冻蛋奶冻，因为那是通往著名的泰德德鲁斯冷冻蛋奶冻的高速公路。44岁。
Farty far. You know, lady, this scene was bonkers, and we got a fan question from Finn and Grand Rapids who said what did standards and practices have to say about the conference room scene? Yeah, what did they? Finn, I was so glad you asked. I asked Steve Burgess. He said the only notes that we got on this episode were from a table draft version of the script. We would have read this at the table. There was a scene where Erin is at her computer the next morning and she's looking up information on impotence. The scene description read like this quote, Erin is at her computer. We get a look at what's on the screen. A site reading
44岁。你知道的，女士，这个场景太疯狂了，我们收到了来自大急流城的芬恩的粉丝提问，他说审查标准和实践部门对会议室场景有什么看法？是的，他们有什么看法？芬恩，我很高兴你问了这个。我问了史蒂夫·伯吉斯。他说我们收到的关于这一集的唯一意见来自剧本的桌面草稿版本。我们在围读剧本时会读到这个。有一个场景是艾琳第二天早上在电脑前查阅关于阳痿的信息。场景描述是这样的，引述如下：“艾琳在电脑前。我们看一眼屏幕上的内容。
impotence causes and solutions with a drawing of the male reproductive tract. Aaron notices the camera and quickly turns her monitor away. Nelly walks up and then Nelly was gonna notice her monitor and Nelly says, well, look who's not so boring after all. I'll show you where to go for the really naughty stuff. And then it said Nelly walks around the desk and begins to type something in the computer. So when we turned that script into standards and practices, here's what they had to say. Page 17. As discussed with Steve Burgess,
一个显示‘阳痿的原因和解决方法’的网站，配有男性生殖道的图画。艾琳注意到镜头，迅速把显示器转开。内莉走过来，然后内莉注意到了她的监视器，内莉说，‘哦，瞧瞧谁其实并不那么无聊呢。我来带你去看看真正淘气的东西。’”然后上面写着内莉绕过桌子，开始在电脑上输入一些东西。所以当我们把那个剧本交个审查标准和实践部门时，他们是这样说的：第17页。如与史蒂夫·伯吉斯所讨论的，
examples of the male reproductive tract, one of which will be seen on Aaron's computer, will be sent to us for our review at your earliest convenience. Please keep in mind because of the subject matter, the visual may still have to be blurred. Hmm, just keep that in mind. Well, this scene ultimately ended up being cut before we shot it wasn't even in the shooting draft, and Steve Burgess said, we received no other notes about the shooting draft, or the final cut, and absolutely nothing at all about the conference room scene. I feel like standards and practices was on sort of remote leave or something during Steve Burgess's era.
男性生殖道的例子（其中一个将在艾琳的电脑上看到），将在方便时尽早发送给我们以便审查。请记住，由于题材原因，视觉效果可能仍需要进行模糊处理。嗯，只要记住这一点就行。好吧，这个场景最终在我们拍摄前被剪掉了，甚至不在拍摄剧本里，史蒂夫·伯吉斯说，我们没有收到关于拍摄剧本或最终剪辑版的任何其他意见，对于会议室场景更是绝对什么都没收到。我觉得审查标准和实践部门在史蒂夫·伯吉斯那个时代可能处于某种远程休假状态。
Apparently they cared a lot about imagery, but maybe not so much about our discussion. But there was also no as previously stated. No. None of that. Well, lady, I did a deep dive on impotence. What? I did.
显然他们非常关心画面，但可能对我们的讨论没那么大兴趣。而且也没有像前面说的那样。没有。完全没有。好吧，女士，我对阳痿做了一番深入研究。什么？我真的做了。
I thought, why not? Here's what I'm going to tell on impotence. What? I did. I thought, why not? Here's what I'm gonna tell you I found out. It is normal to have trouble getting or keeping an erection for up to 20% of the time. So any just man having a sex life, yeah. If you aren't able to maintain your erection 20% of the time, that's considered normal and no reason to see a doctor.
我想，为什么不呢？这是我要告诉你的关于阳痿的发现。什么？我真的做了。我想，为什么不呢？这是我要告诉你的我发现的东西。在高达20%的时间里遇到难以勃起或维持勃起的情况是正常的。所以任何有正常性生活的男人，是的。如果你有20%的时间无法维持勃起，这被认为是正常的，没有理由去看医生。
If you experience it more than 50% of the time, that's when you should seek medical evaluation. And there's a lot of medical issues that can cause erectile dysfunction and you should get checked out. And the list is long. I mean, there's, you know, heart disease and all kinds of things that could be leading to this problem. So fellas, go to the doctor. Important. But there's other things as well. Could be your age, depression, anxiety, PTSD, stress, in Andy's case, I think stress. Oh yeah. And to sell these issues, they
如果你在超过50%的时间里经历这种情况，那就是你应该寻求医疗评估的时候了。有许多医疗问题会导致勃起功能障碍，你应该去检查一下。这个名单很长。我的意思是，你知道的，有心脏病以及可能导致这个问题的各种各样的事情。所以伙计们，去看医生吧。重要。但还有其他事情。可能是你的年龄、抑郁、焦虑、创伤后应激障碍、压力，就安迪的情况而言，我认为是压力。哦，是的。为了解决这些问题，他们
recommend improving your lifestyle habits first. Stop drinking, stop smoking, exercise, reduce your stress, and if those things don't help, you could try therapy or medications or testosterone replacement therapy. For mild ED, you can try a penis pump, and as a last resort, you can try surgery. You can get a penile prosthesis. And I looked it up. It involves putting an inflatable rod in the middle of the penis. This is also used in gender affirming surgeries.
建议首先改善你的生活习惯。戒酒、戒烟、锻炼、减轻压力，如果这些没有帮助，你可以尝试治疗、药物或睾酮替代疗法。对于轻度ED，你可以尝试阴茎泵，作为最后手段，你可以尝试手术。你可以植根一个阴茎假体。我查过了。这涉及到在阴茎中间放置一个可充气的杆。这也被用于性别肯定手术中。
I read a lot about this, Angela. It's a very sensitive surgery. It has a very long recovery time. It's like six to eight weeks until you're kind of comfortable again. But 86% of people report being really happy with the results. I really got curious about like who came up with this. I'm always fascinated by that. Like who was the first person to think of putting a rod in the penis. And then who's the first person who agreed to be the first patient?
我读了很多关于这方面的资料，安吉拉。这是一项非常敏感的手术。它需要很长的恢复期。大约需要六到八周你才能再次感觉舒适。但86%的人报告对结果非常满意。我对是谁想出了这个点子非常好奇。我总是对此着迷。就像谁是第一个想到在阴茎里放一根杆子的人。然后谁是第一个同意成为第一个病人的呢？
You know? Who was like, I'll try that thing that's never been done with the most sensitive area of my body. Yeah. Well, doctors have been working on this for a very long time, back in 1889. That's what got me into the history of erectile dysfunction medicine, which goes back very far. The first thing that someone tried in 1889,
你知道吗？谁会说，我会尝试那个从未在我的身体最敏感区域做过的事情。好吧，医生们为此工作了很长时间，早在1889年。这就是我进入勃起功能障碍医学史的原因，这可以追溯到很久以前。1889年有人尝试的第一件事是，
a famous neurologist injected himself with dog testicle extract. He took some, I guess, extract from a dog's testicles and put it in himself. There's too many jumps for my mind to make for that, like how, what dog, how did you get the sign? I guess extract from a dog's testicles and put it in himself. There's too many jumps for my mind to make for that. Like how, what dog, how did you get the dog to stay? No, lady, I don't know.
一位著名的神经学家给自己注射了狗睾丸提取物。我猜他从狗的睾丸里提取了一些提取物并注射进自己体内。我的大脑无法接受这中间太多的跳跃，比如怎么做，什么狗，你是怎么得到的签名？我猜他从狗的睾丸里提取了一些提取物并注射进自己体内。我的大脑无法接受这中间太多的跳跃。比如怎么做，什么狗，你是怎么让那只狗呆那儿的？不，女士，我不知道。
He said that he got increased energy levels, but then a series of follow up trials were done and it like really debunked. Like there was no, it doesn't work. Leads dogs on the way. Yeah. In the 1800s, doctors started injecting people with sheep testicle extract. I don't know why they thought the leap from dog to sheep would be, you know what I mean?
他说他的能量水平提高了，但随后进行了一系列后续试验，这真的被揭穿了。就像根本没有，这不管用。路上带着狗呢。是的。在19世纪，医生开始给人注射羊睾丸提取物。我不知道为什么他们会认为从狗到羊的跨越会是，你知道我的意思吗？
It's like if the dog thing didn't work. Textical. Why would the sheep thing work? Are these doctors thinking that some thing from animal balls will help human balls? Well, you know, I think it's the logic of like, if you took some cells from a healthy liver and put them in a diseased liver, it would fix the diseased liver. That was a lot of early medicine. Like, if I just give it some of a healthy version of itself, then don't change my habits or whatever.
这就好像如果狗的方法不管用。睾丸。为什么羊的方法就会管用呢？这些医生是在想，动物蛋蛋里的某种东西能帮到人类的蛋蛋吗？好吧，你知道，我认为这背后的逻辑就像，如果你把健康肝脏的一些细胞放进病变的肝脏里，它就会修复病变的肝脏。那是早期医学的很多做法。就像，如果我只是给它一些它自身的健康版本，然后不改变我的习惯什么的。
Yeah. The first records of a penal prosthesis were in the early 16th century. A doctor made a wooden penis, hope a man who had suffered like a penal amputation, and it was successful. Isn't that a phrase where you're like, I got a woody? Did it come from the wooden penis? I don't know.
是的。阴茎假体的最早记录是在16世纪初。一位医生用木头制作了一个阴茎，帮助一个遭受过阴茎截肢等痛苦的男人，而且成功了。这不是有一个短语是你就像，我有了一根木头（我勃起了）吗？它是不是来自那个木头阴茎？我不知道。
I don't know. Because he was clearly walking around with a woody for the rest of his life. He probably became known as woody in the village. I guess it really helped him, though. A lot of the early Penile surgeries were to help people pee again after a penile trauma. But, Angela, shout out to your alma mater, Baylor University. Baylor University, because urologist F. Brantley Scott is credited with the modern penile implant that we know today. Well, I did not read about that in the alumni
我不知道。因为他显然在余生里都带着一根“木头”到处走。他可能在村里被称为“木头人”。我想这确实帮了他很多。早期的许多阴茎手术都是为了帮助人们在阴茎外伤后再次排尿。但是，安吉拉，向你的母校贝勒大学致敬。贝勒大学，因为泌尿科医师F·布兰特利·斯科特被认为发明了我们今天所知的现代阴茎植入物。好吧，我在校友通讯里没读到过这个。
newsletter. Well, but it will give me something to talk about next time I'm on campus. He got a nice write-up in the New York Times when he passed away and it mentioned his contribution to science and the world of erectile dysfunction and penal implants. But modern medicine is amazing. And you know what, it's not going to come to that for Andy. He's not going to be needing to go there. Maybe if season eight had continued. there. Maybe if season eight had continued. There it is everyone more than you ever wanted to know about how to cure erectile dysfunction. Things are really going to escalate now and Andy's going to get pretty worked up. He's going to
好吧，但这会给我下次在校园里时提供一些谈资。他在《纽约时报》去世时得到了很好的报道，其中提到了他对科学界以及勃起功能障碍和阴茎植入物世界的贡献。但现代医学真是太神奇了。你知道吗，安吉拉不会落到那一步的。他不需要去那儿。也许如果第八季继续下去的话。在那儿。好了，各位，这就是关于如何治愈勃起功能障碍的你想知道的比以往更多的全部内容。事情现在真的要升级了，安吉拉要抓狂了。他要
hang up on his dad. He's going to punch a wall. Aaron's going to throw stuff. They've had it. They're done. And we talked about this scene with Claire, but ultimately they end up sitting on the couch at front reception. And Aaron says, you know what? Maybe we'll be sent to anger management together. And Andy says, you know what?
挂掉他爸爸的电话。他要打墙一拳。艾琳要扔东西。他们受够了。他们完了。我们和克莱尔聊过这个场景，但最终他们坐在前台的沙发上。艾琳说，你知道吗？也许我们会被一起送到愤怒管理班。安吉拉说，你知道吗？
That might be kind of nice. There's some of the guys I want you to meet. And that's when Robert says, hey, come into Nellie's office. And Robert tells Andy, he's gonna put him back on the sales team because Nellie's gonna be the manager. And Andy says no. Mm-hmm. And Robert's like, that's how it's gonna be.
那可能挺不错的。有些家伙我想让你见见。就在那时罗伯特说，嘿，进内莉的办公室。罗伯特告诉安吉拉，他要把他调回销售团队，因为内莉将成为经理。安吉拉说不。嗯。罗伯特就像，事情就是这样。
And Andy's like no. And then he's like, Andy, if you say no, one more time, you're fired. And he says no. Yeah. So he packs up his stuff and he's actually happy. It's like, for the first time, he feels like he has his life back.
安吉拉就像不。然后他说，安吉拉，如果你再对我说一次“不”，你就被解雇了。他说不。是的。所以他收拾好东西，实际上他很高兴。这就好像，这是他第一次觉得他找回了自己的生活。
He's got something else back too. Yeah, swing. Yeah. He's like, let's go, Aaron, right now. That kind of finishes out the Andy Aaron storyline for this episode, but it really doesn't clear up what exactly is gonna happen with Andy and his job as manager. That'll be next week, I guess. Yeah. And Aaron just threw stuff at everybody. We don't know what's up with her either.
他也找回了别的东西。是的，摇摆。是的。他说，我们走吧，艾琳，现在就走。这算是为这集的安吉拉和艾琳故事线画上了句号，但这并没有真正澄清安吉拉作为经理的工作到底会发生什么。我想那将是下周的事了。是的。艾琳只是把东西朝每个人扔去。我们也不知道她是怎么回事。
I just like to ask, what do you have to do at Dundar Mifflin to actually get fired? I mean, remember Aaron quit the whole saber thing. And yet when she came back, expected that she still had her receptionist job back and now she's thrown stuff all over the ground and he's punched a wall. He was MIA for how long? Can you get fired from this job? Well, if Ryan is any proof, no. Oh, Toby is really ineffective. Yeah. Well, someone else is pretty angry in the office today and it's Ryan. He's going to charge into the break room and confront Pam and say, Hey, I heard you've been, you know, talking crap about me to Kelly. And she's like, Listen, if you really insist and I feel like I've said this before,
我只想问，在邓德米弗林你得做点什么才能真的被开除？我的意思是，还记得艾琳辞去了整个赛伯的工作吗。然而当她回来时，期望她还能保住前台的工作，现在她把东西扔得到处都是，而他打了一个墙洞。他失踪了多久？你从这份工作里被开除吗？好吧，如果瑞恩能证明什么的话，那就是不能。哦，托比真的很无能。是的。好吧，办公室里今天另一个人也很生气，那就是瑞恩。他要冲进休息室质问帕姆并说，嘿，我听说你一直在（你知道的）对凯莉说我的坏话。她就像，听着，如果你真的坚持的话，我觉得我之前说过这个，
she doesn't she say she's a forgive me, but I feel like I've said this before. I don't like you. Yeah, I don't think you're a good person. I love how direct and succinct Pam is when she's speaking to Ryan. I know. She's a totally different person when she talks to Ryan. He brings out this whole other side of her. There is no gray area, no misunderstanding. Nope. There is no gray area. No misunderstanding. Nope. There's gonna be a debate between Oscar and Kevin and Pam about whether or not Ryan or Ravi is better for Kelly.
她难道没说她请求原谅，但我觉得我之前说过这个吗？我不喜欢你。是的，我觉得你不是个好人。我喜欢帕姆跟瑞恩说话时的那种直接和简练。我知道。她跟瑞恩说话时完全是另一个人。他激起了她完全不同的一面。没有灰色地带，没有误解。不。没有灰色地带。没有误解。不。奥斯卡、凯文和帕姆之间将展开一场辩论，讨论瑞恩还是拉维更适合凯莉。
They all are like, oh no, it's Ravi. It's 100% Ravi. Mm-hmm. Even Nate, who's never met Ravi, prefers Ravi. Over to Brian. Yes. We call him. I don't know if you noticed in the scene, I am eating a peanut
他们都觉得，哦不，是拉维。100%是拉维。嗯。甚至连从没见过拉维的内特也更喜欢拉维。而不是瑞恩。是的。我们叫他。我不知道你有没有注意到在这个场景中，我正在吃一个花生
butter and jelly sandwich and then I have some yogurt in a Tupperware container. I thought it was an interesting lunch and I think maybe I just really wanted to eat a peanut butter and jelly sandwich. Yeah. Their peepie and jays were really good. I would also. It was the bread. It was the bread. I was looking at it and my gluten-free self was really craving that PBJ. Mm-hmm. Now everyone is gonna leave for the day but what is waiting outside in the parking lot?
酱三明治，然后我有一个特百惠容器里的一些酸奶。我觉得这是一顿有趣的午餐，我想可能我只是真的很想吃一个花生酱三明治。是的。他们的PB&J（花生酱果酱三明治）真的很好。我也会的。是面包。是面包。我看着它，我这个不吃麸质的人真的很渴望那个PB&J。嗯。现在每个人都要下班了，但停车场外面在等着什么？
Mm-hmm. It's Ryan on horseback. He is in a type of traditional Indian dress as is the horse, jinx. I was very curious. Did you ask Steve Burgess how much that cost? Yes, I did. It cost $2,500.
嗯。是骑着马的瑞恩。他和马“金克斯”一样穿着传统的印度服装。我非常好奇。你问过史蒂夫·伯吉斯那花多少钱吗？是的，我问过。花了2500美元。
The horse was an Indian wedding horse that we found online and Bob done contacted the company and brought the horse out to us. The horse came with wardrobe. There were two choices for the horse's wardrobe and we picked this one. That's amazing. Well Ryan is now from horseback going to give a speech to Kelly if he can ever get the horse to turn around. This is what his speech says and it's really what every girl wants, fellas. He says, Kelly, I can't promise you that we'll always stay together. I can't promise you that I'll never cheat on you.
这匹马是一匹我们在网上找到的印度婚礼马，鲍勃·邓恩联系了这家公司，把马带给我们。这马自带服装。马的服装有两个选择，我们选了这一套。太棒了。好吧，瑞恩现在要从马上对凯莉发表一番演讲，如果他能让马转过身来的话。这是他的演讲内容，伙计们，这真的是每个女孩都想要的。他说，凯莉，我不能保证我们永远在一起。我不能保证我永远不会对不忠。
Nor should I. Modern marriages aren't built that way. Men aren't built that way. There's a very interesting article I can email to you, but I can tell you this. Even if the odds are 50-50 that will break up within the week. I want to roll those dice. I love you, Kelly.
我也不应该这样做。现代婚姻不是那样建构的。男人不是那样建构的。有一篇非常有趣的文章我可以发电子邮件给你，但我可以告诉你这个。即使我们在一周内分手的几率是50对50。我也想掷这枚骰子。我爱你，凯莉。
But Kelly says, No, I choose Robbie. Yeah. I love you Kelly. But Kelly says, no, I choose Robbie. I love him. But then she asked for a hug. And then they start making out. Well, here is something interesting. This scene was scripted to end with Kelly finally, after an uncomfortably long period of time, pulling away from kissing Ryan and saying, good bye friend, but we cut that. That changes everything. Yeah. I think it's good that we cut it though, because it really is gonna play out later,
但凯莉说，不，我选择罗比。是的。我爱你，凯莉。但凯莉说，不，我选择罗比。我爱他。但随后她要求一个拥抱。然后他们开始热吻。好吧，这里有个有趣的事。这个场景原本剧本写的是以凯莉在经历了一段令人尴尬的漫长时间后，终于从吻中抽离出来瑞恩，然后说，再见，朋友，但我们把它剪掉了。这改变了一切。是的。我觉得我们把它剪掉挺好的，因为这在后面确实还会上演，
but Ryan will always be with Kelly. We got a fan question from Chris L and East Brunswick, New Jersey, who said, in the scene where Ryan gives a less than perfect proposal to Kelly, dressed in traditional Indian wedding garb, when he is on the horse and he says, turn around. And the horse trainer says he doesn't want to turn around. Was that scripted or improvised? Chris, it was scripted. That the horse would not turn around. Yes.
但瑞恩将永远和凯莉在一起。我们收到了来自新泽西州东不伦瑞克的克里斯·L的粉丝提问，他说，在瑞恩身穿传统印度婚礼服装向凯莉进行不太完美的求婚的场景中，当他在马上说“转过去”而驯马师说“它不想转过去”时，那是剧本写好的还是即兴发挥的？克里斯，那是剧本写好的。马就是不肯转过去。是的。
And that Ryan would have to do his whole speech to her facing backwards. And even him saying, can you turn this fucking thing? Yeah. Even him cursing was scripted. I want to give a shout out to the horse Wrangler, guest star Miles Cranford. Miles did not become an actor until later in life. I was reading his bio online and it said that he always loved
而且瑞恩必须背对她完成他的整段演讲。甚至包括他说的那句“你能把这破玩意儿转过去吗？”是的。甚至连他的咒骂也是剧本写好的。我要向驯马师兼客串明星迈尔斯·克兰福德致敬。迈尔斯直到晚年才成为一名演员。我在网上读他的简历，上面说他一直热爱
acting, but he got a bachelor's degree in science. And in his lifetime, Mark does a teacher, a firefighter, a financial services manager, a ranch manager, and a certified hotel administrator. But later on life, he realized his true passion was acting. The office was one of his earlier jobs after changing careers, but he's been in so many things. He is now a full-time working actor and Angela fresh off the boat crossover. Hey.
表演，但他获得了科学学士学位。在他的生命中，马克当过老师、消防员、金融服务经理、牧场经理和认证酒店管理员。但在晚年，他意识到自己真正的激情是表演。这部剧是他在改变职业后的早期工作之一，但他演过太多东西了。他现在是一名全职职业演员，而安吉拉，这是新来的跨界串场。嘿。
Our new crossover. It's our new monk. The episode's gonna end with a call back to something we forgot to mention, which is earlier in the episode, Ryan says that he wrote Kelly, the best poem ever. And Pam's like, read it, please. He's like, no, it would crush you.
我们新的跨界串场。是我们新的神探阿蒙。这一集将以一个回扣结束，我们之前忘了提这件事，那就是在这一集的前面，瑞恩说他给凯莉写了有史以来最棒的诗。帕姆就像，读一下，拜托。他就像，不，这会击垮你的。
You couldn't even handle it. And everyone's like kind of egging him on to read it and he won't read it. Well, Pam finds it in the trash and Jim's like, what are you doing? She's like, don't you wanna hear this poem? And they start to read it. Yeah, they read the first two lines.
你根本承受不了。每个人都在起哄让他读，而他就是不肯读。好吧，帕姆在垃圾桶里找到了它，詹姆就像，你在干什么？她就像，你难道不想听听这首诗吗？然后他们开始读。是的，他们读了前两行。
Yeah, it starts like this. Kapoor and Kadezesprit, he watches. He is a drifter out to sea. And then there's kind of a time cut. Yeah. And we hear the last line of the poem. And when the Indian Ocean calms, one speck of white remains in waters cold and Kelly green. Pam is choked up. Yeah, she's like it's so dumb but when he describes himself as a child lost on a life raft. And then Jim is Terry. And his final talking head he says, Ryan can never know. This poem really got them. We had a fan question from Angela F. in St. Louis wondering if there was a full-length
是的，它是这样开头的：“卡普尔与卡代什精神，他注视着。他是大海上的一名漂泊者。”然后中间好像有一段剪辑。是的。我们听到了这首诗的最后一行。“当印度洋平静下来，一抹白色残留在冰冷的水域中，化为凯莉绿。”帕姆哽咽了。是的，她说这太蠢了，但当他把自己描述为一个在救生筏上迷失的孩子时。然后詹姆很严肃。他在最后的单人独白中说：“瑞恩绝不能知道。”这首诗真的打动了他们。我们收到了来自圣路易斯的安吉拉·F的粉丝提问，想知道是否有瑞恩这首诗的完整
version of Ryan's poem. Angela, I'm sorry, no. I looked for it too. I St. Louis, wondering if there was a full-length version of Ryan's poem, Angela, I'm sorry, no. I looked for it too. I know. I was so hoping there was something in the candy bag. Anything. No. This is all we'll ever know of the poem.
版本。安吉拉，我很抱歉，没有。我也找过。我圣路易斯，想知道是否有瑞恩这首诗的完整版本。安吉拉，我很抱歉，没有。我也找过。我知道。我多希望糖果袋里有什么东西。什么都没有。不。这就是我们对这首诗所能知道的全部了。
Yep. That moved Jim and Pam to tears. Well, that was Angry Andy, everyone. Thank you so much to Claire for stopping by and talking with us about her time on the show. And thank you, Steve Burgess, for giving us all the details on the horse and the messages from standards and practices. And to all of you for writing in every week, we absolutely love rewatching the show and
是的。这让詹姆和帕姆感动得流泪。好吧，这就是生气的安吉拉，各位。非常感谢克莱尔停下来和我们聊她在剧中的时光。也谢谢史蒂夫·伯吉斯向我们透露了关于马以及审查标准和实践部门留言的所有细节。还要谢谢你们每周写信来，我们真的非常喜欢重看这部剧并
sharing it with you. We hope you have a great one. No we're thinking of you and we love you. We'll see you next week! Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jennifer and Angela Kinsey. Our senior producer is Cassie Jirkins. Our in-studio engineer is Sam Keeper. Our editing and mixing engineer is Jordan Duffy.
与你们分享。我们希望你们过得愉快。不，我们在想着你们，我们爱你们。我们下周见！感谢收听“办公室女士们”。“办公室女士们”由Earwolf、詹妮弗和安吉拉·金斯利制作。我们的高级制作人是卡西·吉尔金斯。我们的驻场工程师是萨姆·基珀。我们的剪辑和混音工程师是乔丹·达菲。
And our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbico. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的副制作人是艾斯利·布比科。我们的主题曲是克里·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。你 这个剧集目前还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。